we ready to start this show
I can't hear you
[Music]
mine's added on my own battle ready for
the storm ain't Wanna See Me Whip watch
me imma prove I'm wrong
Make some noise
[Music]
coming up first to the stage dedication
extraordinaire Vincent oh Shawna
[Music]
and last but certainly not least the
sauce man Adam saws
thank you
I know this life meant for me yeah I
know it's meant for me the struggle
won't get to me and now the moment that
we've all been waiting for your host
with the most standing at 6'4 weighing
in a 240 pounds Patrick
yeah Patrick told me brother let's make
it let's go
[Music]
friends and family think I'm crazy
[Applause]
so it's crazy because uh we bought this
building my dad said you got to buy this
building you know we bought this
building
for one year there was nothing going on
here oh literally we have nothing going
on here for about a year and a year
later we said why don't we turn it into
a comedy club
and then from The Comedy Club
um where's Rob at
Rob when do we decide on turning the
back into a cigar lounge
how long did it take us to build it out
some of you guys are going to see it
that back there's a cigar Give It Up to
Robert by the way
shout out to Robert and the team okay
what do you think about this uh
structure this idea you like this idea
you like this whole concept of what
we're doing we're going to see what's
going to happen with us quite frankly
one of the models we live by is we have
no clue what the hell we're doing but we
know exactly why we're doing it okay we
have no clue what the hell we're doing
but we know why we're doing it uh we got
a lot of crazy stories to go through
today with you the team's been very
prepared for the audience out there
that's watching us on podcast we wish
you were here with us there's a couple
hundred people in here by the end of the
podcast we're going to turn off the
camera we'll do some questions with the
folks here I'm sure you're gonna have
some questions you want to ask we'll
have some of that interaction by the way
can we have the lady stand up I just
want to get a ratio of men versus women
the audience okay all right we're
increasing we're increasing this is good
thank you grab seats it's it's now
here's a question with the ladies that
are you how many are here because your
husband forced you to be here that's the
real question okay that's what I'm
talking about good fantastic how you
guys feeling you're doing good and how
many of those women are single though I
think most of them are probably taking
only one in the back okay we're good too
okay all right so we got a lot of things
to cover we got a lot of stories a few
things that we will go through rob you
got to remind me to do the sponsorship
in about 10 minutes
every time I forget so if he forgets can
you guys remind me make sure to do the
sponsorship that's his job Rob remind me
here my wife is here as well Jen can you
please stand up so everybody can see out
our first one awesome okay so we got a
few stories Morgan Stanley Deanwood says
the Market's gonna go down 26 percent
2.3 trillion dollars of equity lost in
homes the last 12 months 2.3 trillion
dollars of equity loss in the last 12
months we're going to talk about the
five dirtiest cities in America some
statistics on the leading cause of death
for kids today versus what it was 40
years ago the the stats that came out
first of all when you see the chart were
you shell-shocked when you saw that job
you will be shell-shocked when you see
this chart on what the stats of kids
dying today the the age they give us
well anybody heard about what happened
with that uh the five Consultants flying
in from Little Rock Arkansas out to Ohio
East Palestine did you hear about the
plane crash or no you haven't heard
about that wait till we show you this
clip on what happened there uh there is
a very um deep concern I have that uh
New York Times is about to be canceled
because they're actually telling the
true true stories they talked about
masks so it's a very something maybe
we'll talk about what they said about
masks and then uh uh we're going to talk
about Trump versus DeSantis just out of
curiosity how many guys are team Joe
Biden raise your hand Make some noise
I saw two hands almost go up you can't
do that you gotta say something Make
some noise for team Joe Biden nobody's
willing to do that there's one
all right Make Some Noise if your team
DeSantis
really
I could make some noise if you're team
Trump
would you say 50 50 or Trump slightly
louder Trump 60s slightly louder how
about team Newsom
absolutely
it's pretty wild it's going to be an
interesting poll we'll do here in a
minute yeah okay let me let me read this
story to you and then uh we'll get right
into it so the first story we're going
to do
is Morgan Stanley if you want to go to
page nine Morgan Stanley Dean with a Rob
if you want to put this up so the
audience can also see it
Morgan Stanley says SMP could drop 26 in
months strategists are warning the US
equities are becoming too expensive
which could cause the S P 500 to slide
by as much as 26 percent
in the first half of 2023 this is not
the Year this is first half so June 23rd
June 30th recent data suggests that the
U.S economy might avoid a recession
however it has also taken the
possibility of a Federal Reserve uh
pivot off the table making it less
optimistic for stocks the sharp rally
this year has made stocks the most
expensive since 2007 according to the
equity risk premium metric which has
entered the debt Zone Morgan Stanley's
Michael Wilson said that the risk reward
ratio for equities now is very poor the
FED is still far from ending its
monetary tightening interest rates are
higher across the curve and earnings
expectations are still too high by 10 to
20 percent Tom what are your thoughts on
the story well I think what you're
seeing here is I'll translate this into
plain English Morgan Stanley doesn't
think that the economy is getting better
and it's going to be represented by a
market drop in plain English you could
take a look at what happened just a day
ago the market everybody see about Diego
the market dropped six seven hundred
points like in one afternoon it was
triggered by Home Depot because Home
Depot talks to home renovations also
there's a large percent of Home Depot
earnings that come from when you buy a
home you get rugs Windows drapes paints
you need a lot of stuff new lawnmower
all these things and Home Depot came out
and said yeah fourth quarter wasn't that
good and we don't think 23s can be very
good at that moment is when the market
dropped because they were really scared
about what's happened in retail Morgan
Stanley is looking at it and saying hey
you know what this thing could this this
thing is fragile how fragile
Home Depot makes an announcement by noon
and by the afternoon you've lost six
seven hundred points so what Morgan
Stanley is saying is that the economy is
more fragile and they think there could
be a real drop and we just saw it live
uh Walmart came out that afternoon too
with some kind of bad news and there it
is live for you it's a very fragile
economy it's what they're saying and
they see it could drop 26 percent Adam
what do you think
so this is Morgan Stanley right I'm
going to use the uh by the way hi
everybody great to see everybody
everyone we want a great looking
audience yeah holy moly yeah let's just
give some credit to the audience looking
our audience looks way better than I
thought uh even you Trump supporters out
there who look way better than I thought
oh
uh I think in the immortal words of Big
Lebowski uh Morgan Stanley that's like
just your opinion man so it's we've seek
we see whether it's Goldman Sachs or
Morgan Stanley or the big Banks the
wirehouses or Credit Suisse or UBS
everyone has an opinion if if there's
anything I've learned about the economy
and the financial markets nobody has a
effing clue what's going to happen I
remember when when covet happened and
um what was that March of 20 right and
the economy tanked and I'm in a group
chat with all my buddies and one works
for Goldman Sachs and he we're all like
dude like what's what do you think he's
like well I actually sold all my
equities uh a month prior and we're all
like what the [__] tell us dude what
happened and what happened six months
after that the economy the market
bounced back tremendously so I think
what we what we've seen as far as the by
the way how many people invest in the
stock market here a show of hands so
like the majority of the room who was
like no way I don't mess with equities
I'm all real estate Commodities all
right so a couple Biden voters out there
like a couple but
um what we've consistently seen is
anytime there's a bear Market which we
just saw covet exactly a bull market
follows right up after that time after
time after time so at the end of the day
you have to figure out what your age and
your asset allocation is so the majority
of this room good looking people looks
like in their 30s 40s 50s maybe anybody
retiring or like trying to pull out
their 401K money anytime soon I doubt it
so maybe you got to talk to your mom
shout out to Vinnie's Mom right there
watch your 401k Mama but if you're not
pulling out of the market if you're not
selling if just like if your home equity
goes down 20 stock market goes down 20
if you're not selling it's called
realized gains uh I wouldn't make
necessarily be a concern maybe you have
an asset allocation strategy to be a
little bit more conservative but this is
not a major worry for me well how about
we go into the next story which kind of
goes together with this 2.3 trillion
dollars in value lost in equity in homes
how many of you have felt it have you
felt losing equity in your area or no
have you guys felt it now yes can you
raise your hand if you are some of you
guys are on real estate you're not how
many guys have lost money equity in your
home but you don't want to admit that
the fact it's lower than what it was six
months ago okay that's a different Camp
to be a part of Rob I notice a lot of
head nodding but not hand uh raising
housing market downturn wipes 2.3
trillion dollars in value as experts
predict prices could still tumble
another 10 percent the total value U.S
homes has fallen a record high 47
trillion dollars I'm sorry uh uh there's
no 42 a record high of 47 trillion in
June Collective value to now 45.3
trillion uh representing the largest
June to December drop since the subprime
mortgage crisis in 08. though home
prices are up uh 1.5 percent over the
past year the median price has fallen
about eleven and a half percent from a
pica 433 in May 383 in January as higher
mortgage rates drive up borrow costs and
sideline potential home buyers last week
U.S home purchase applications fell to
28-year low that's a big number Tom 28
Euro to U.S Home applications huge 28 is
what that's a
1995 1990 1995 so a long time ago 28
year low
hardest risk area hardest hit areas
include regions adversely affected by
waves of Technology layoffs and
skyrocketing prices during the pandemic
include San Francisco Oakland New York
San Fran is down seven percent Oakland
is down four and a half New York is down
a point Pantheon macro ultimately
projects home prices will fall about 20
percent from their Peak by the end of
the year suggesting the median price
could tumble another 10 to 346. go ahead
Adam well I just I kind of want to throw
this back to you because you've taken a
lot of heat for kind of calling this
people would come up to me or to you and
say does Pat want real estate prices to
go down and I think that raise your hand
if you've heard Pat talk about this on
the podcast so raise your hand and
you're in real estate and you still
that's the real question yeah
so every realtor is going to say no the
Market's fine it's all good great time
to buy it's like really uh
you just bought a house a year and a
half ago yeah top of the market some
would say yep
um so what's been your strategy and and
you're not anti-real estate you want the
market to go up you don't want to go
down but you're also a realist so what's
been sort of your outlook strategy of
why you've been you did a whole uh
wealth generational wealth real estate
you've done a couple webinars on that
what's been your mindset when it comes
to real estate 15 years was the last
time we had a market crash that's a long
time 15 years oh wait we haven't had one
for a long time we're overdue we've
never had a season where more fake money
has been pumped into the system like
today we have a lot of fake Equity we
have a lot of fake success we have a lot
of fake Millionaires and too often fake
success or fake millionaires is just
like somebody winning the lotto you
don't have the identity of it so you're
overspending your over leverage you have
so many different things that you're
paying on your concern you're afraid
when a buyer comes in like the other day
we were looking at the property uh 6500
Federal it's down the street a block
away we went all looked at it they
bought this property in 08 for 13 and a
half million commercial real estate
so we go look at the property beautiful
place 54 000 square feet uh you and I
went in there rob you and I kind of very
much so went in there and looked at
every single floor and we come up with a
suit the ladies like can I help you when
I think I said yeah we're working with
management we're just checking on this
property to see everything good yes
everything good fantastic thank you so
much we're just looking around you know
uh uh the buyer is asking for eight and
a half million dollars and he bought it
at 13 and a half in 2008 okay this
doesn't mean it's happening Everyone by
the way 2008 is not a peak 06 was Peak
right 2008 Market tank 38 so again the
people who have cash and made the right
choices and they're ready for this
they're going to Skyrocket and kill it
and make the kind of money they've never
made before the people that had a lot of
fake success in the last few years and
they kept spending money they're going
to get exposed and they're going to get
destroyed and I don't think this is the
end of it think about it this way right
now who controls the most important knob
who controls okay Jerome Powell controls
the most important knob what number is
he trying to lower inflation to two
percent where are we at right now six
and a half what is six point four six
point five percent what is the only
thing he can do to lower it right
according to Tom he wants to go up to
the attic and start banging out some
interest rates
how many more times do you think he's
going to be increasing rates right well
I I agree with what Adam says about
analysts because a lot of analysts you
know words are just words until they're
numbers I like to look at numbers and
there's a lot of people from the real
estate I think he was calling you out
honestly publicly and I was offended by
it and I would be upset if I were you I
don't like it but notice what's
happening Tom is starting to agree with
Adam a little bit more weird so we'll do
something to maybe have a fight today
for the audience that thinks we don't
like each other but they really don't
like each other don't let them know
that's that's Mario where's Mario go
ahead Mario over here no no problem no
problem screw you very much anyway the
um
the um
so the numbers that I'm looking at that
we see in what you're talking about real
estate here is is a couple things the
supply of homes is at the lowest that
it's been in about it's it's more than
that it's like 20 years the supply for
sale that's a real number the number of
buyers that are in the market is at a 28
year low that's a real number and you
hear the real estate industry they make
their comments and everything and I kind
of look at it this way saying I don't
only ask the butcher whether the meat is
fresh right I confirm I want to confirm
it so when you look at this and you look
at where the FED is I think the fed's
got three more rate increases and that's
an estimate but the estimate is coming
become we just had a really strong jobs
report and we've had some false
positives in certain earnings reports I
mean if you bought Tesla at the early
January you doubled your money in the
last 35 days right now it's settled at
200 but there's a lot of those things
that are in the market meanwhile it all
comes back back and it kind of hits kind
of hard folks were believing that the
Fed was going to raise rates this year
maybe two more times quarter points well
just a week to two and a half weeks ago
they threw a quarter point at us and
they're coming back out on March 15th
and March 15th is a date where they will
also make economic projections and make
all those numbers reports and everybody
now is looking at it and saying you know
what I think the fed's going to raise a
half a point and Powell is making
comments like he's going to raise a half
a point right now the Fed rate is 4.75 a
half Point that's 5.25 the so-called
experts Goldman Sachs Morgan Stanley
last November were saying well 5.25 is
like the maximum we see and then it's
going to be dropping down at the end of
second quarter we're right now with
inflation factual numbers certainly
doesn't look like it's going to drop and
people believe that on May 3rd and June
14th the fed's going to put another
quarter point based on what we're seeing
in the hot job market which means that
the interest straight is probably going
to hit five and three quarters not just
five and a quarter what does that mean
for housing if it hits there that means
the interest rates which right now they
they popped up those have been real
estate we saw a pop up over the last
three weeks right in rates I think rates
right now I'm seeing some nods that if
you uh kind of a below average credit
you're probably looking at seven and a
quarter right now
um having popped up on the 30 and the 15
maybe six and a half
and so those rates are going to be up
close to eight I don't like this news so
people that have said things to Pat or
myself on Twitter oh you guys are bears
you don't like the housing market no the
housing market is people it's us it's
citizens it's buying a house it's
getting into something and these are
facts here these numbers that are not
pointing to a rebound in housing in the
first half of this year along with it
looks like Jerome Powell is going to
make three more trips to the attic to
visit the cheerleader and bang what were
you saying about the butcher what was
the butcher analogy you said well I like
to say this is I don't just ask the
butcher whether the meat is fresh I also
want to confirm all right well there's a
famous quote from the philosopher Tommy
Boy you guys ever seen this you said you
can get a good look at a T-bone steak by
sticking your head up a cow's ass but
I'd rather take the butcher's word for
it you know about this yeah 100 so I I
what I do want to you guys don't know
about that one shout out to Thomas
you're talking about pounding up in the
attic and Tommy Boy what I do want to do
is share a story that that
um you know Pat will calls me up one day
and I live in Miami and uh he's like
what are you up to I'm like I'm just uh
in Miami he's like come meet me at the
uh Hadid building remember that which is
the by the way if you can put up the
Hadid building it's a beautiful building
it's a woman's body
essentially building right that's kind
of like a thousand put a thousand
Biscayne Miami
it's a beautiful Village beautiful
building so there's overhead that looks
like a woman yeah there's
the hell kind of girl are you talking to
the artist who are you dating by the way
the designer is a woman she died Gigi uh
the Hadid family you know Bella hadiji
yeah this is their aunt uh she died
while it was going on I actually lived
at the building to the right of it and
to the left of it so Pat goes I could
not afford to live in this building this
is like David Beckham lives there and uh
hedge fund guys it's like minimum uh I
want to say 10 million dollar entry
we're trying to get there but he goes
hey uh come meet me at this building are
you familiar with that I go yeah I lived
right next door for for 10 years so we
go there and we go to the penthouse
right sick unit
and it was listed at I want to say 40
million dollars give or take
and uh it was actually hilarious we're
on a tour Mario's with us and the lady
comes to me and she says like so what
are you doing I go well you know I'm
here with my boyfriend Mario
but he says it with a straight look on
it good and uh meanwhile she goes to
Mario and she's like so what are you and
your boyfriend looking for he's like
I like to mess with Mario a little bit
but Pat says no you got to finish the
story Mario's like who's my boyfriend
she's like well you and Adams that's not
my boyfriend says you know what I really
didn't see you guys together I didn't
see that though he was I would get a way
hotter guy than Mario for sure but uh he
is he is shout out to Mario getting
married and uh having a baby let's go
Mario I mean amazing so we've we've got
a brotherly love thing going on so we go
to this building it's a 40 million
dollar unit if not more and uh
Pat has his realtor that that you
brought and the the unit had their
realtor and Pat says listen let me just
cut to the Chaser this up hat kind of
negotiates he says I'm gonna make an
offer they're like great he goes but
it's going to be very disrespectful
she goes please don't don't do that
don't disrespect me he's like it's going
to be a disrespectful offer and it was
listed for 40. I think they bought it
for 30. I want to say
Pat says I'm gonna offer would you would
you offer 13.
13. I thought it's a fair offer 13
million cash 24 hours three
spitting your face disrespect
they said no but I think they countered
at what number 20 23 23 good upselling
at 19. ended up selling at 19 did it
sell it sold four so here's my point
we're talking about the market we're
talking about real estate here's a unit
that was a ridiculous unit gorgeous he
even teased me with like what do you
think can you see yourself living here
and I'm like Pat don't even play with me
right now so
that's just an appointed example of
these luxury markets that have majorly
taken a hit I mean even your situation
with your car that I don't know if you
want to talk about that but some of
these asset prices have been inflated
and it's coming down to reality and I
think we should have bought that for 18.
but by the way you because you would
have you would have taken care of you
would have been a house what a house
what a generous house that are you on
right there's rumors out there that
women are doing more of the working and
men are staying at home I would gladly
stay at home we have a by the way that
is a story we will cover him here in a
minute but uh uh no you're right here's
the part that concerns me a car payment
my dad uh wanted a car okay so I said my
dad's like just give me anything you
know my dad drives a uh for I don't know
how many years he drove that 1979 diesel
until the day he said when this engine
dies I'm gonna die this is how strange
my dad is the day the engine dies
he thinks he's dying
yes or no babe he went to the hospital
two weeks they said sir you're okay says
no the engine on my Mercedes died the
doctor's like that's a car you're a
human being he says but we're gonna die
same day no you're not sir you're still
living anyways so I said now let's just
buy you a car you know let's just buy
you what kind of car do you want do you
want a you know do you want this car do
you want no I just I just want a regular
car I just want a regular car finally
gems like babe do you know what the car
payments are on a regular forty thousand
dollar car I said how much babe like I'm
thinking 500 bucks or whatever right no
babe 850 I said for what it says if you
want to lease a car or get a car today
here's the first thing do you know right
now is the highest car payment average
car payment in the history of America
you know what the number is it went up
200 bucks in a year so it went from like
540 to 770 in a year Middle America's
income hasn't gone up 40 or 20 how the
hell are people 700 right there yep the
average car payment in the history of
America is the highest it's ever been
and it's climbing so why is it climbing
car prices are now climbing car prices
used car prices are coming down watch
prices are coming down collectible cards
are coming down Bitcoin you know where
it's at ethereum you know where it's at
so luxuries in every possible way are
going down because people buy not saying
this is a million dollar Home People by
saying I can afford a six thousand
dollar a month payment that million
dollar home six thousand dollar a month
payment today is eight thousand dollars
seventy five hundred dollars how do you
come up with that additional fifteen
hundred dollars if you didn't get the
raise so what are people gonna be doing
with this it's automatic you have to
either desperately the people that
bought a house that they couldn't afford
hoping they're gonna make two three four
hundred thousand dollars of equity
they're stuck right now so imagine if
these guys so right now the only
indicator that people uh ought to be
watching closely and by the way thank
you for the reminder to go to our
sponsors here in a minute uh Adam you're
wonderful yep yes sir uh uh here's the
biggest indicator that concerns me
unemployment today is 3.4 percent okay
it's a 60-year low unemployment is 3.4
percent 60 or low when you think about
unemployment
and interest rates being high
unemployment is low if they lower
interest rates unemployment is going to
go up if this 3.4 goes to 4.4 5.4 if
we're at 5.4 people don't have income to
pay their car payment and their mortgage
payment and their bills what are they
going to do they're going to have to
start dumping what they have and they're
going to dump it for pennies on a dollar
because they don't have a choice so that
is my speculation of what's going to be
happening if this goes on and so I have
to go to my sponsors and I know you want
to talk about the five dirtiest cities
in America now I know you want to talk
about Trump and the Santos but first
let's go to our sponsors okay so my
sister the other day I get a message on
Instagram from her and she says Patrick
I I took this Bitcoin training program
and it changed my life
and I'm like babe what the hell is Paula
talking about she says I got the message
too
I said my sister's number she sells
Insurance she's part of our company what
I mean she's doing Bitcoin change your
life so I'm like how did it change your
life and so now I'm communicating with
my sister
and then she's saying what she's saying
so yeah let me take this program with
this girl named Linda I'm like
babe who the hell is Linda babe
so so
I'm like she's babe and then the
pictures posted of a Tesla without her
obvious it's just a picture of Tesla
says that my life's been changed I just
bought my dream car this this that like
Paulette didn't buy a Tesla okay so
finally I said babe I called Paulette
She's Like Pat I've been hacked so I
realize I'm not talking to Paulette so I
said hey that's awesome I'd love to
learn how you made this kind of money
because I got a friend of mine here
sitting right next to me would you guys
like me to read what I told this guy
that's trying to hack my Bitcoin it's so
entertaining you will love it so look
what I told this guy he was so concerned
this is when you troll the criminals out
there here's my response I said I have
my friend here who's also wanting to
learn his name is federal agent Huntsman
you've met him before at the house he
right now works on internet Bitcoin
Fraud Unit and would like to know as
well how it works sometimes these things
are frauds and he can look into and make
sure it's not a fraud they're able to
identify IP address and Instagram
accounts to identify level of
credibility just last month his team
identified 17 fake Instagram account
fraud organizations and work directly
with the local agency in that country
who has seen an increase in these frauds
and arrested them their Pros are what
they do Paulette be careful they
typically hack and get access to their
user ID and pass password and take
advantage of innocent users who trust
you to make sure this is you please call
my cell if I don't hear from you and
suddenly I get blocked or don't get a
response it'll tell me this account has
been hacked the FBI will do their part
she got her password the next day by the
way just so you guys know that response
a good script to write down when you get
a message like this here's a point boom
nowadays whether you know or not a lot
of people's passwords are on the dark
web our guys have tested this multiple
times uh two of our guys 38 of their
passport was on the dark web one of our
guys was 41 another person was 44. if
you are not taking care of your identity
theft to protect it it's officially
number one above robbery Aura is
Identity Theft Protection and fraud
monitoring a VPN password management and
anti-virus software all combined into
one easy to use app you may have one of
these tools but not having all of them
is like locking the front door but
leaving a back door wide open protect
you and yourself from America's fastest
growing crime try Aura for free for two
weeks and see if any of your or your
families from personal information
has been compromised start your 14-day
trial at aura.com forward slash pbd once
again aura.com forward slash pbd the
link will be below so having said that
can your FBI friend agent is he figural
get the money that I sent your sister
listen one of the best things you might
remember that one time that one guy
called me and he says yes uh I want to
teach you uh Patrick David's Bitcoin
system yeah so I called them do you guys
remember when they would make the
comments by the way sometimes people
make these comments so I call them I
said so do you work directly with
Patrick Davis Bitcoin we recorded this
it's on YouTube he says I work directly
with Patrick David I'm like you got to
be kidding me I said how crazy is he and
he says well you know he's a I can't
tell you we can't disclose client
information anyways eventually you have
to know there's these people out there
if you're not too careful we went to
Angelo's the other day we're at Angela's
having lunch this good-looking guy who's
always good to us he comes and he says
hey I signed up for your program
Adam was like what program did you sign
up for he says I signed up for your
Bitcoin program I give 200. he said I
don't have a Bitcoin program as crazy as
it is you're getting a lot of these
stories can I say one thing about that
he was the nicest waiter shout out to
Angelo's out there it's like the best
Italian restaurant Patty so he's the
nicest waiter he's serving us all like
everything hand and foot and at the end
of the bill he goes hey by the way I
just want you to know the Bitcoin
program that I signed up for it's so
good I did that's you got the wrong guy
but it's real this is like a real thing
that we did okay so did you want to say
something before we go to the 5 30. no
just get my money back okay so let's do
this with the five uh let me do this
with the five dirtiest cities so story
comes out pretty wild five dirtiest
cities in America if you want to put it
up okay can anybody who's who who's read
this article reason if you read the song
who has not read this article who has
not read the song can you guess well he
put it up already I was about to say it
you screwed it again okay a new study by
lawn starter has found that the top five
dirtiest cities in America run by
Democratic Mayors I would have never
guessed it obviously it's a surprise
what it's not like we brought this up
when we talked to uh uh Roland Martin
which was a fantastic friendly
conversation sweet shout out to him for
being here I respect the fact that he
showed up Houston ranked first
for the dirtiest City anybody here from
Houston by the way anybody oh we got a
couple people from Houston we love you
Houston my wife's from Houston we got
nothing against Houston if you got any
complaints write to this guy what's his
name let's see who it's Jessica Jessica
uh is writing this article Houston is
the dirtiest City followed by Newark San
Bernardino Detroit and Jersey City these
cities were measured across four
categories pollution living conditions
infrastructure and consumer satisfaction
Houston was rated as the dirtiest City
in rent ranked third on pollution fourth
on poor living conditions and 12th on
infrastructure and 34th on consumer
satisfaction Virginia Beach the cleanest
city in the country is ran by a
Republican mayor Robert Dyer the City
ranked 149th on pollution and 132nd on
consumer satisfaction Tom why why would
this be a factor for cleanest and
dirtiest cities ran by Republican or
Democrat what do they have to do with it
I think when you go to a world of
entitlement and you're not allowing look
when business invests what do they do
they build a building they build areas
around the building you're investing in
it and when you take a look at all these
things this is the outcome of
entitlement Houston I think and Rob you
could find this is like number one in
worse traffic in America poor
infrastructure investment they managed
to pass Los Angeles which has had like
the World Cup of bad traffic four or
five freeway oh my gosh yeah it's it's
incredible and what this is if you fail
to invest in the infrastructure and
you're just running on tax the rich and
entitlement you're not really improving
the condition of the city and this is
what you get this is the outcome and you
go down all these lists that people say
this this this this and this and they
say wow you know take a look at this and
I don't think it's a coincidence that
it's you know Democrat you know
administrations I think dirty has to do
with politics you think dirty has to do
with Democrat and Republican like like
for crime I understand when we're
talking crime 27 out of 30 because we
talk about the fact that you're funding
into so so let me ask you a different
question what can a mayor do to make
their City cleaner what can a mayor do
what policies can a mayor come up with
to make their cities cleaner I you know
when you enable entrepreneurship and you
enable job creation people have jobs and
people and you're going to reduce
homelessness so anybody that's been the
San Francisco sees with the outcome of
chronic homelessness looks like in LA
you get people off the streets and you
have the ability to reinvest in schools
and you have the opportunity to do this
you know it's very simple if you promote
economic growth and tax it reasonably
you've got money to work with to improve
your city it's that simple and not being
political how then how is it I mean it's
technically political because of the top
five damn dirtiest cities are Democrat
and in the top five were with Roland
Martin you said that for crime like
Chicago it it is well they're all
Democratic but to me the way I go is if
it's crime I say okay Chicago got it
what do you do well you don't have guns
you don't have you know license to carry
let's just say or certain way they
handle structure for second amendment in
Chicago versus another city that's maybe
in Idaho or how they handle it here or
how to handle it in Texas then you can
kind of say fine that makes sense and
then hey let's defund the police or
let's what's the word the other word for
defunding the police it's a asset uh
reallocation which is another definition
for defunding the police then you can
directly say there's a reason why this
City's crime is so high but dirty dirty
is what how do you What policies cause a
city to be cleaner
What policies yes please
show use jails inmates to help come and
clean the cities okay
so leverage them to come in and help
clean the cities I that's the part but I
wonder if it's on the people if it's on
the mayor I mean obviously the leader of
the city has to figure out a way to make
make it cleaner but what policy do you
come up with like is it you know like
the uh uh how many guys have a city
where if you get caught loitering
there's a ticket to it there's uh
literally not like you your your uh yeah
when you're littering there's a ticket
to it do you guys it's not 100 but so
what you're saying is Pat just like the
meter maids why not have people like on
the street like I know Los Angeles has
safety ambassadors they don't have guns
or anything they just kind of like if
there is like a somebody yelling or
there's an argument they come to kind of
I was hoping to solve all the problems
on today's podcast we're failing right
now guys just so you know well I have an
I have an idea uh well why don't we get
Mayor Pete who's the uh the mayor of
South Bend Indiana now the department of
uh Transportation yeah secretary okay
yeah I think there's a new top
uh dirtiest city in America right now
yes Palestine Ohio yes I know they're
dealing with a lot with that
um I I this I don't think there's any
simple fix here's what I do know
um like what do you think the biggest
city the biggest city in the country
that voted Republican in the last
election Trump
what do you think the biggest city was
anyone
200 people here nobody's got a big city
that you think voted
so there's zero big cities that have
voted Republican zero the top 50. so you
know think about even the red Estates
Alabama okay what's its capital of
Birmingham Democrat Texas Dallas
Democrat uh go down the list uh we we
all know the Republican states we know
the red States okay but the the bigger
the city the more people the more
liberal they tend to be the more open
they are to new ideas now some of it is
a little ridiculously far-fetched but
the more conservative the cities the
more that they're kind of like let's
just stay how things are so I think the
bigger the city gets the more likely it
is to have a Democratic mayor so so you
just well that's a different
conversation though so let's finalize
this topic and let's go to the next one
here's what I would say I think it is a
cultural thing the more I by the way I
wasn't I don't have like the solution or
the answer to it did you guys see what
happened at World Cup when Japan came
and played what they did afterwards did
anybody see the clips right afterwards
what happened did you see this or no
they cleaned all this bleachers
fans yeah they cleaned everything after
themselves and you're like wow yeah so
then other countries who were playing
they were kind of like let's do the same
thing as well and it became like a
cultural thing for us to Yeah clean up
there they go and and you're like wow
this is not what we do in Germany or
this is not what we do in U.S or this is
not what we do in such and such and
other people started picking it up I
don't know I think if somebody from the
top is speaking about it you definitely
can do something about it you know the
whole San Francisco story have you guys
been to San Francisco lately or not who
is part who's from San Francisco
actually anybody from San Francisco have
they started cleaning up San Francisco
is it can you say it louder to the
people in the back that can't hear you
and he's from San Francisco right so
just 10 years ago babe when was it you
and I went to San Fran we'd go there
regularly was that eight years ago 10
years ago five years ago
we went when we went to Napa you're
right yes and
AIG I remember that and and the place
well by the way great meeting you was
there so the place was cleaned and you
look forward to going to San Francisco
versus today you go to it we were there
I'm like what the hell is going on look
at this yeah this this does not look
like San Francisco looks like a complete
different city the responsibility is on
the mayor I guess one of the things
could be said is what is the standard
that you take with homelessness what is
the standards that you take with fines
what is the standard with cultural they
were hey what if we had a one day
cleaning day let's all get out there and
clean the city what if we did something
culturally that we can make this place a
better place what if we did something
like that you know remember the day that
in California to deal with gas they did
the one day you couldn't drive uh who
remembers that one day who remembers uh
anybody remembers 405 was closed or the
one-on-one what was it called
how long ago was that like
2013 when they did that and it was one
day everybody took a break and it was
one way of doing this imagine you're the
mayor of a city you're like listen guys
here's what we're doing uh we have
gotten the top 20 CEOs of the top 20
companies in our city and here's what we
got all the CEOs to agree to do one day
paid leave
to go out there and all of us volunteer
to clean our city wouldn't that be a
sick idea if somebody who would vote for
that how many guys would be like yeah
I'm okay we're going out there doing
supporting it I think it's something
like that that they got to do to clean
their cities Houston's not growing
because it's a bad City they just went
from number four four years ago they
paid passed up Chicago as a number four
City to now number three a book that was
written 15 years ago called the next 100
million we spent time with this author
at somebody's house in Malibu and he
said by the time the next 100 million
people are born in America Houston will
be the number one city in America wow
this book is called that's the book if
you want to zoom in on the book when did
it come out 2010 13 years ago uh uh uh
the day the next 100 million people are
born in America by 2050 he predicts
Houston will be the number one city in
America it's a big city we just moved a
couple of our guys to use it sounds like
they're getting your message about
having babies out there in Houston if
there's any message I got that's parents
raise your hand I'm just curious let's
do a quick survey keep your hands up if
you got more than one baby more than two
three or more
four or more
five or more with the same life with the
same wife
[Laughter]
yeah there we go
he's like well it's got like four wives
by the way funniest Story one of our
agents seven years ago he comes he says
I want you to meet my kids
I said great met the kids I said how are
your kids so they're both 19. so when's
When's her birthday well he's June and
she's July
so I want to ask the question but I
don't want to ask the question because
his wife is right there
so I'm like
so then he says
I know what you're thinking I was a wild
man okay but my wife forgave me we're
together I have two kids and they were
pregnant at the same time I said okay so
how's your insurance business known for
you right I would change the subject
keep your hands up if you had four three
of you guys raised in if you had four
raise your hand if it's five anybody
five really five five officially your
LDS and I know Joel you're not LDS right
six
six all the way can you stand up please
if you're at six
he's tired are you really at six seven
seven kids make some noise
your husband's here as well
[Applause]
your husband's at home
oh first of all I I'm telling you you
don't look like a grandma but seven kids
I can't see you from here freaking
congratulations to you that's awesome
thank you for your granddaughter who's a
marine thank you for her service I think
we need to have more kids guys and I
know you don't want to hear this I'm on
a campaign to talk to every man and by
the way specifically leaders
specifically leaders if you're a husband
and a wife we had a couple people at the
house over two days ago you remember
these two guys that were over
and one of them is a Jewish father
he just came back from Israel he's got
two kids
and he says well you know my wife wants
me to have more I said dude there's no
way you can stop at two kids he says why
not we're making money we can put time
into our two kids why should we have
more than two kids I said
12 years ago one of my uh uh uh you know
advisors was a guy named John Morris Tom
you remember John Morris you introduced
me to John Moore's incredible guy we're
in a meeting one time one of the guys
about to go out of business he needs a
half a million dollars he says if I
don't get a half a million dollars by
Friday I'm gonna have to shut it down he
makes a phone call an hour later the guy
gets a half a million dollar stays in
business like that's the kind of a guy
John Morris is anyways I said John in
our monthly meeting how many kids you
have John two kids you two kids yeah
you're 60 years old two kids you're
small why two kids biggest mistake of my
life
it's the biggest mistake of your life
it's the biggest mistake of my life so
tell me why he said tell me what think
in our lives we stop doing the moment we
get very good at it
he says that two kids I barely learned
how to be a parent and then I stopped
having kids we should have four then I
came home I started campaigning payments
for four but David's four now he said
but David's four five we ended up with
four but to those who have money you
teach the right values and principles
please look up to that lady back there
and go have seven kids can you please do
that because others are having more kids
and you need to be having more kids all
right let's go to the next story let's
go to the next Story by the way are you
guys following this East Palestine story
closely or no what's going on here so
let me tell you what happened with our
guy so
I'll show you a video
of should we first read this article or
just show the video so they know what's
going on here well anyways there's five
Consultants that are traveling from
Clinton airport no joke Little Rock
Arkansas
they're flying to
Ohio East Palestine to check to see
what's going on here's what happens to
them if you want to play the video first
if we have it ready wrap uh let's let's
watch this video together go ahead and
play it yeah break news tonight have a
plane crash in Little Rock Arkansas just
minutes ago we learned the people on
board were actually headed here in
Northeast Ohio to help clean up the
Oakwood Village explosion from Monday
all five people on board work for
environmental consulting firm the plane
took off from the Clinton National
airport around noon and was headed for
John Glenn Columbus International
Airport right now we are digging into
the story we will have much more on air
and online as soon as we learn it
I mean
so we can obviously say it's appropriate
to say what a strange coincidence yes
fine
what do they go in there to look for so
we have a new member of the
valuetainment team we're testing
something it's a guy named Dodge do you
have Dodge's video we flew out Dodge and
Malik
to East Palestine to see what's really
going on because I believe a bunch of
people visited there uh uh uh we know uh
Pete hasn't been there he's got a very
busy schedule he's very busy schedule he
hasn't been there yet it's been 18 days
he still hasn't visited President Biden
was in Ukraine on President's Day he
hasn't visited there but we said Trump
was there yesterday I believe he was
there yesterday or two days ago I think
it was there yesterday Wednesday and he
was at McDonald's so this is our guy who
was there show called Dodge segment
called Dodge this and he actually drinks
the water watch this video drinks the
water the same there has to be some
semblance of a cover-up the residents
have not been given the correct
information in a timely and efficient
manner not enough people have been given
enough funds to successfully relocate
for a safe amount of time
and the relocation payments of people
for evacuation was only in a one mile
radius meanwhile you're seeing dead fish
all the way out to Cincinnati you're
seeing the water contaminating
Youngstown this goes on for hundreds of
miles Beyond this one mile radius
contamination Zone
so there are a lot of residents even in
this town that are not receiving the
help that they need so that's why we're
here at valuetainment we're actually
talking the residents we're telling
people how they can help and we're
getting the truth because quite frankly
if you listen to any governmental entity
Republican or Democratic doesn't matter
a lot has been left off the table in
terms of what they're telling us
so that's why we're here and
a lot of people are too scared to do
this
we didn't ask him to do it watch this
oh my God he actually does this
this is the actual water
oh my god dude
what tastes like metal
he died 20 minutes later
he's not with valuetainment anymore
tasted like somebody dropped about a
million pennies into it what are you
doing almost blood-like taste now I'm
not gonna drink a whole glass
and what you saw I wouldn't do that
watch my hands the water that I did have
and just in case you didn't see it
before watch this
are his hands getting ready
yo
there's the water
ah
terrible
near the river and actually look at
What's Happening Here Give It Up to
dodge
you can watch the whole clip we'll put
it up he talks to all the people out
there and Vinnie what do you think's
going on what are your thoughts on this
whole story well well first of all since
you said the Clinton uh situation I
don't know if anybody's been following
who Mark Middleton is one of uh Bill
Clinton's top aides uh last year in May
I know Adam loves these type of stories
I saw your body language I love it hold
on I'm not hold on I'm not a conspiracy
theorist and I love people just brush
off people have different opinions I'm a
coincidence theorist okay his name is
Mark Middleton you guys could look it up
last year in May this dude he was the
top uh Clinton official worked in the
white house he led Jeffrey Epstein into
the White House to visit seven out of
the seven put up the storms put up the
stores I mean I texted to Rob this dude
at his house in Arkansas
oh yeah right here so he was Syrian for
who speaks of Syria we have a very big
assertive community so this dude top
eight ties with um Jeffrey Epstein he
was found hanging in a tree with a
extension cord around his neck gunshot
to his chest no gun found apparently a
squirrel took it and sold it on the
black market but yet they just ruled it
uh yesterday that it was a suicide so so
wait so this is I'm a conspiracy
theorist because he's tied to all this
stuff Epstein all this information is
coming out there's no gun but you can't
even I can't have another opinion
because automatically they dismissed me
as I'm a conspiracy theorist but it's
true Pat think about people to Jet
somebody just walked up to him the other
day uh reported from daily uh mail and
they're like so P when are you going
he's like I'll talk to you later I
talked to my press Corps you saw this
time and then at the end he goes you
know what let me take a picture of you
what is he gonna do with that that was
sweet took a picture of the reporter
they took a picture of the reporter hold
on why is that a threat are you
threatening this person like yo we're
gonna come come find you it's just it's
just people say oh you're connecting
dots the dots are right in front of your
face if you don't connect them then
you're just like one of the and you
brush it off but is that weird is that
another weird thing these people died
what were those people on the plane
going to do in East Palace you're a
pretty reasonable guy what do you think
is going on there you know when too many
coincidences line up you you start you
start to wonder
um not wonder about your own sanity but
you really start to wonder about it and
and you look at it when things are in
plain sight you know if it's a bunch you
know long drawn out article by people
with the tin hats you say okay never
mind go away but you know like Mark
Middleton how do you shoot yourself and
then hang yourself in the extension cord
in a tree very hard to do and there's no
gun
you get some sort of award in the
suicide Hall of Fame for doing it yeah
that's how you got to do it right it's
almost like you hang you shoot and you
gotta you gotta chug you like hard good
really good yeah Fido grab the gun
it doesn't well and you know this this
whole plane crashing into a grassy knoll
and that you know the lady that noticed
it was going down from the six-story
window of The Book Depository you know
that's kind of odd to me I mean it's
like odd coincidences it just really
really bothers me it's like New York in
the 80s and you would see you know that
a guy shot six times was pulled out of
the Hudson River it's like well if he
was pulled out of the river and
naturally he'd drowned right yeah of
course so Adam you have any uh reality
theories for us to kind of uh balance
the conspiracies or not that I'm I'm not
I'm not anti-vinnie's conspiracy
theories I just like trying to get to
the heart of the problem I think you
know like we're unraveling this onion I
think first and foremost there was a
tragedy with this train situation in
East Palestine Ohio I think like that's
the the core of it yeah and everyone
wants to make it political well if it's
political
the governor is actually Republican so
is it on Pete butterjudge who's the
Secretary of Transportation to address
this to me
um all these other stories kind of just
try to build someone's Narrative of what
they think happened I think it's a
freaking tragedy we talked about on the
podcast
how many train accidents happen a year
it's insane thousands I think this was a
horrible one a deadly one and now when
you when you when you I think it's just
a sheer coincidence these people are
coming from Clinton airport I think you
know speaking of accidents every day you
turn on the news a plane crashed today
into a small building it's like yeah
because it's [__] Tuesday that's what
happened but Adam what are the odds of
them go they're going to this place I
get it but I think we're trying to
without much information trying to piece
together a narrative I think it's a
tragedy what happened in this situation
I think they need to get to the bottom
of it and the plane crash is just
and just a pure anomaly planes crash all
the time yeah I'm not I'm not like
here's where I'm not going go ahead God
here's where I'm not going the true
reports called Clinton is nothing crazy
for 74 people the train crashed with the
chemicals was actually done on purpose
to hide the fact that they were
basically was happening the same day
that the Epstein report was coming out
and they're trying to take the news away
from no he brought Epstein from a
different place
what people's story has nothing to do
with East Palestine Epstein is not from
East Palestine the island is not in Ohio
just so people know going around saying
have you been to the Epstein Island in
Ohio I think yeah ultimately what I'm
trying to say is like let's address the
issue there's something going on in Ohio
right now and our friend Dodge just died
of drinking water okay so let me ask you
a question then so uh conspiracy or
coincidence theories aside how do you
feel that if the president of the United
States is nowhere to be found he's over
there are throwing our money away while
we have people dying here Pete Buddha
judge and I know you're saying I don't
care if it's a Republican mayor Governor
whoever the the head guy of
Transportation hasn't even talked about
it that doesn't that doesn't piss you
off that doesn't bother you that listen
that guy should be the normal guy Trump
going there Trump going there but I
don't care he was a McDonald's throwing
Big Macs at people I don't get somebody
one of my friends is like who's kind of
on the left he's like what cut why
McDonald's I go bro it's East Palestine
there's nine people there there's no
more in Steakhouse you know what I mean
can I tell you guys something very weird
when I'm when I'm watching this by the
way strategically think about this here
for just let's just purely talk strategy
okay let's set aside the emotions for a
second all we're talking a strategy when
you go to war people get you know die
and of course nobody wants to see family
Innocent but as a general a general has
to be in a moment making tough decisions
let's talk purely strategy if it's pure
strategy how did the scientists go from
winning by only 34 000 votes to win
winning one and a half million votes in
the great state of Florida how did he do
it did he do it because
he only went to Republican counties did
he do it because he only went to
Republican cities or did he do it
because he won Miami-Dade how did he do
it he's the greatest Governor we have
right now in America because he went and
won people over dinners being had we're
having lunch at the house what did Mikey
said he says they're having dinner with
a guy who's a liberal hardcore liberal
he says when they asked him the question
about the sentences what do you mean the
sentence he says the best Governor he
says he's a republican he says we don't
look at our uh Governor as a republican
he's just a great governor and we want
to keep him here and they'd love to vote
for him as a liberal this guy converted
people so watch this strategically
strategically not going help to
Republicans strategically you mean to
tell me you're not going guess what Pete
here's what's going to happen when
foreign affair issues comes up they're
going to bring one question for you
you're done all they're going to say is
hey so how would you handle the issue
there and then the opposition is going
to say what yeah half a war was to take
place it would take him four weeks to
make a decision it would cost millions
of people lives do you really want a
president like that he couldn't handle a
small City like East Palestine you want
him to be the decision maker of a
country of 330 million people he's not
qualified to be a president boom you're
fired five seconds later get off the
stage right so Pete is done with what he
did for 2024. now let's go to the other
part here's what's weird very weird
so yesterday who goes to East Palestine
Trump trump
so if you go to go to YouTube uh Rob and
and just go to YouTube's uh go to Fox
news's YouTube channel go to Fox news's
YouTube channel okay so this I watched
the last okay go to videos go to videos
click on that can we put on the screen
so everybody can see it okay so Trump in
2015 2016 if you go back and look at the
videos on Fox News literally every three
video was about Trump so Trump just went
to East Palestine of the last 50 videos
that they just uploaded how many of them
should be about Trump of the last 50.
what do you think it should be of the
last 50. 5 10 should be about Trump
watch this let's count one two three
four five six keep going seven eight
nine keep going 10 11 12. find this
picture on the boom former Trump donor
reveals why he's supporting possible
DeSantis run this is a anti-trump story
keep going Ned Ryan is Trump political
witch hunts all end up as bad jokes keep
going negative negative story East
Palestine residents praise Donald Trump
right now keep going Hannity Tucker keep
going next next next keep going next
next next I went and watched CNN CNN
hosts
praise
Trump really how confusing is that he
says listen say what you say about Trump
he showed up wow and Pete Buddha just
should show up I don't know why he's not
showing up he should they said I
understand why Biden didn't show both
Republican Democrats are saying we
understand why Biden was in Ukraine for
the one year anniversary if you're
already committed 50 billion it's a
total of 100 billion dollars we've given
to Ukraine of which around 50 60 billion
is our money it's a total 100 billion
we're the number one country with the
most money being given to them
you have to show up because that's
checking on your investment if that
makes sense if you're investing into a
company and you own 50 or 60 percent of
the equity company one year anniversary
what do you got to do you got to go to
it he still has to go to East Palestine
yeah but he's gone and done that no
problem Pete budic has zero excuses CNN
is giving a shout out to Trump Fox isn't
giving a shout out to Trump including
Sean Hannity Sean Hannity discussion on
East Palestine was only a few seconds
CNN talked about him visiting East
Palestine so what is this telling you
here's what it's telling you fox today
is team DeSantis Fox is no longer team
Trump just everybody knows this part
here Fox is no longer team Trump as of
right now it's purely the sentence
whether you like it or not go to your
own research listen to these guys so I'm
willing to bet there's a conference call
or a conversation saying pump the brakes
if we're going to go 14 Trump if we're
going to go full team DeSantis we feel
better with the sentence right now the
polls are coming out I got a couple
posting on popularity where the sentence
is showing ahead over Trump so Fox is
taking that position CNN on the other
side they're also looking at this saying
well
the Santos just has uh the most
impeccable resume today okay it's hard
to beat his resume say what you want to
say you have to explain 34 000 to one
and a half million you can't win that it
doesn't matter what anybody says I went
from having 34 000 subscribers and I've
increased it by 1.5 million subscribers
go ahead and beat me what's your
argument say whatever you want and more
people are coming to my state and we're
safer and we're this and we're that and
we're this that's a beautiful resume so
that part that Trump who had Fox News
Trump who had Hannity Trump who had
everybody on Fox when he was on the
shows that's going to be missing today
so I think this kind of leads me to the
conversation about Trump and DeSantis
with head-to-head match up what it's
going to look like and Trump is still
making the comments how many guys don't
like it when Trump says I would never
call him meatball I would never call him
meatball I would never call him does
that bother you or do you kind of find
that funny when he does that how do you
take that by the way you guys don't have
an opinion on that do you see when he
says the meatball stuff or do you like
it or you don't care if he does it
that's who he is
you don't care about it okay so some
people made a comment about this and I
want to get your thoughts some people
said like here's a tweet from a couple
days ago I will never call Ron the
sanctum the sanctumonius meatball Ron as
the fake news is insisting I will even
though Fox knows killing light well Paul
Ryan is revert by him low energy Jeb
Bush is his hero and always had his side
his beaches and states were closed for
long periods of time his testing testing
testing for the China virus didn't work
out too well and his loyalty skills are
really weak it would be totally
inappropriate to use the word meatball
as a moniker for run a lot of people
don't like this commentary on what Trump
said I'm gonna go to our friend first to
see what he thinks about it Adam tell me
what do you think about the approach
Trump has taken with around the center
just you got to understand Trump's humor
here it's like I don't care what you
tell me to do I'll never call him
meatball no I'll never do it never in a
million years am I going to call him
meatball Ron I'm not going to do it no
matter how hard you incur urged me to
call him meatball Ron the sanctimonious
I'm just not gonna I'm not buddy I told
you I'm not gonna call him meatball Ron
it's like we've seen this shtick uh
unfortunately
uh for Trump and to my friends in the
room here uh the shit's getting old guys
it was very new in 2015. very new
whether you like Trump whether you
didn't like trump it was [__] new it
was like what this guy's on stage
calling out Republicans this is crazy
little hands Marco Rubio I got bigger
hands this is crazy it's it was so new
it was so fresh that people just
it was must see TV at this point even
Fox News is like Ugh just fade away and
they basically said we'll take all your
policies because I've been very clear a
lot of Trump's policies were good for
the country but all the name calling and
the childishness and the the
divisiveness it's like we can do away
with all of that
and just get the same policies with
meatball run and that's I think where
the the the fervor of the country is at
this point and here's my last point if
you want to just win a Republican
primary nominate Trump if you want to
lose the presidency again
go ahead guys Trump 2024. good luck well
in the pack I say one thing though Adam
we'll be in the back for those I want to
talk to them if you have issues with
that you'll be right here but but just
to be clear I will gladly gladly vote
for meatball Ron to sanctimonious gladly
and I'll just call him Governor DeSantis
I won't I will never call him meatball
yeah but here's my question though and
it's for everybody like is anybody
surprised that he's going to be this guy
Pat is anybody like oh my God I
understand that oh my God here we go
again but put yourself in hold on put
yourself in Trump's shoes from the jump
you don't think he has a vendetta from
the beginning he announced everybody and
their mother from Republic and all the
Republicans all the Democrats all the
media all the left they all surrounded
his ass and they went after him bro that
guy and everything now that we're
finding out with Twitter and just common
sense it was all [__] you don't
think he has a chip on his shoulder
where he's like yo I'm coming in hot
he's a winner bro say what you want he's
orange or whatever the hell people say
bro that guy is a winner her he wins in
real estate he he's a freaking boss and
with all the stuff culminating around
what everybody was around him bro he is
in attack mode and guess what he's a
competitor bro when you have when you
know you have Ron DeSantis the meatball
coming up with you bro you got to talk
smack he's he's he's The Golden Child so
guess what I don't I'm not surprised and
guess what the gloves come off he's a
fighter bro and it's gonna be it's gonna
be interesting but it's gonna be a it's
gonna be a hardcore fight let's talk to
a very uh stable man who's a father of
Two Girls
Professor you know just took his kids
they're rock star kids 4.6 GPA one of
the best golfers in the country at 16
years old she is I've watched him as a
father as a businessman as a advisor Tom
tell us what do you think is really
going on here and who do you think is
going to have the edge when it comes
down to winning this whole thing well
there's two things that people need to
understand about Trump
um you don't you don't have to love them
but go look at the videos like when he
sat there with NATO telling them that
they had to pay their fair share and how
he defended America to defend America's
economy go look at how he stood up to
China and said this is the way I'm going
to play this game and then when he gets
out on the field to play the field of
play for politics has been set you do
your sound bites and then all your
proxies go out there and spin it to the
media and then this guy comes out and
says I'm not playing your game the way
you want me to play your game so you are
a disaster and he goes out and he does
it the way he wants this guy brings guns
to knife fights and he does not go
gentle into that good night the way the
political realm goes in America because
the underlying current of running for
pilot running for office in America is
I'm ultimately going to have to make a
compromise with you you and you and get
legislation passed so I'm going to come
hot on certain things but I'm not going
to come in you know really really super
low because ultimately I have to work
work together now the presidential race
we saw it that way we saw it that way
with Romney and Obama that was the last
time we saw it that way with Hillary we
didn't and DeSantis is taking a normal
progression of people love me in Florida
because I executed hurricane I executed
Solutions economy executed solution
co-fit executed Solutions and then
everywhere but Broward County a little
and a little part of Orlando said you
know you're right and I like what you
did to my state and I'm voting for you
and he gets one point
you know almost million and a half vote
differential there he crushed the
opponent well that guy is taking his
normal next political step and he's
running into a buzz saw with a guy that
does not play by the normal set of rules
in terms of the campaign and I'll tell
you you know that's what you're seeing
and you're seeing Trump be Trump and
you're seeing the political
establishment in the media they don't
know how to deal with that here's here's
my uh so I I'm by the way it doesn't
bother me at all you know like uh when
people ask and say hey how could you sit
there with Antonio Brown and he says you
idiot you idiot what you know about
Liberty City and all of them
okay cool I got you okay I'm gonna go to
your city to learn about your city and
I'm gonna go be a Dixie what do you call
it Winn-Dixie and to learn what that
City's all about because maybe I'm an
idiot okay and I'll learn about your
community but here's something he tried
to compare Liberty City to erase the guy
there's guns out here it's like I'm from
Iran from Iran bro how about bombs yeah
it's a big difference yeah you didn't
really understand me boy you didn't
understand yeah this was just the parody
um you're funny it's a parody but but
you know what it is here's a part you
have an opponent if you know your
opponent's dirty and he's dirty and
you're shocked you're a fool
do you understand what I'm saying if
your opponent plays the hardcore
Christian you know Mike Pence do-gooder
you know all this stuff and then
something comes out he doesn't know how
to handle it it's like oh you can't use
that card if a girl came out for for uh
Mike Pence what would the world react
with yeah right buddy no no oh you
wouldn't believe
he doesn't travel without I got his wife
but that is Trump's brand so for people
to say how could you say something like
this you must not have been following
this guy for decades that's who he is
here's my concern my concern is a
different concern there's a reason why
Joe Rogan is the is the goat of
podcasting So Hear Me Up number one he's
super likable super likable like it's
unbelievable how likable he is he's
sincere he's authentic he's straight up
but here's also the other part okay
he draws in the audience of UFC how many
guys love it when Joe Rogan reacts when
a guy gets knocked out oh my God you
know that's like dude we can't wait to
see that and then the meme he's
interviewing everybody with the mic in
the face after whatever happens he's
right it's awesome right these Joe Rogan
memes yeah that picture right there it's
sick it's awesome so Joe can talk on the
topics of UFC now watch this can Joe
talk on the topics of wheat today it's
not a big deal 10 years ago a big deal
can Joe speak on basketball no can Joe
speak on football it's not especially
can he speak on guns can he speak on
Hunting can he speak on Space can he
speak on Ayahuasca can he speak on uh
what's that he can speak on Comedy he
can speak on acting he was in Hollywood
he was an actor he was a working actor
there are so many different genres that
he can have the conversation with so
he's multi-dimensional he's got range
he's got a lot of range on where he can
go to and he knows where he can so if he
can't he brings a guy and he he's won
the best interviews in the world so
guess what he knows how to get Intel out
of somebody that's not his space that's
a strength watch this
2016 when Trump won what did he have he
had Twitter
he had Facebook he had YouTube he had
Fox he had CNN he had mainstream he had
everybody everybody wanted to give him
the platform because they knew if he was
there they're going to get what millions
of eyeballs okay he hasn't tweeted yet
his first tweet will be the most liked
tweet ever but he hasn't tweeted yet
he's still doing truth social because
he's driving to value that company he
can't do that strategy long Facebook is
back Instagram is back he's gonna have
to use those things
um if Fox is not platforming him
regularly if he's not going after them
and fox quite frankly doesn't care
doesn't act like they care right now who
else does he have because you need
someone from mainstream you need someone
from social media you need someone from
business Schwartzman is now saying
they're going to support the scientist
and he Schwartzman was a big that's the
part that he can't yeah he can't you
can't lose those things so by the way
I'll give you guys another crazy number
here do you know how much since Trump
announced his uh candidacy he now said
in November right when did he announced
that he announced that late October that
he's running for office when was it when
he announced when he's running around
that time correct was it late October in
2022 from the moment he announced that
he's running for office he raised 9.6
million dollars in 2022 alone now to be
fair he didn't campaign at all so it's
not like he was campaigning he just
raised 9.6 million dollars do you know
how much Ron raised just running for
governor in 2022 do you guys know the
number 211 million dollars
one state Governor
that's real money okay say whatever you
want to say this guy's getting two and a
half million dollar checks right now
to support him so why do you think that
is though but what the point all I'm
saying to you is you know uh the the art
of raising money is something not a lot
of people can do if you're raised a
million raise mayor is what mayor you
need like a you know depending on the
city you are
Congress you know some of the cities in
Atlanta Georgia that were fighting the
budgets were like 100 million 50 million
remember that how big it got for some of
these cities
but if you're raising 210 Jeb Bush had
the last name of bush he was a two-term
governor when he ran for president he
raised only 140 for president and his
father's a president his grandfathers I
mean you know his brother's a president
his grandfather was Senator Prescott you
started with 140. bro the Santas raised
210 0.9
you have to pay attention to this part
and people vote with their money every
time you want to know like how we vote
the way people go vote at Starbucks
versus uh what do you call it uh Coffee
Bean you're voting with your money if
you go by Ford over a Chrysler that's a
that's a form of a vote that we're
putting in place right so now
this doesn't mean anything if Trump
starts doing his rallies and he starts
creating momentum and he goes on Twitter
and he starts being active on Facebook
and Instagram he's capable of raising
the money now some will say what the the
difference is what who needs the money
who doesn't need the money
Trump doesn't need the money DeSantis
needs to raise the money so that's the
part where he's like well unlike him I
don't need people's money he's bought
that's what Trump's going to say Trump's
going to come and say because that's his
position he's going to say well yeah of
course he's raised that kind of money
you know who's giving them the money
this person that person this person that
person this person he's the institution
he's the establishment he has to do all
these favors for them so you just have
to know this is what we're going to be
hearing the next 12-18 months then going
back and forth and the votes the the
American people are going to make a
decision and they're going to say I'm
gonna go this way or that way but I
think if you think it's ugly right now
by the way I'm telling you this is less
than one percent of ugly yeah we're not
even at 10 of ugly it's gonna get ugly
the moment DeSantis announces he's
running
Trump's going to take out his torpedo
he's going to take you out yeah let's go
guns blazing go ahead I think um
something to consider uh is you talked
about establishment is that so we all
remember when Bernie and Hillary in 2016
was a 2016 and yeah it was 2016. uh and
then Bernie was in the lead and then all
of a sudden
the Democratic establishment the NC
basically a DNC was like Bernie thanks
for everything but we're going to give
it to to Hillary I I don't think that
we're giving a lot of uh thought to
what's happening behind the closed doors
with the Republican establishment
whether it's Mitch McConnell or Kevin
McCarthy or all the bigwigs kind of
behind the scenes they are all
on team DeSantis no question so when you
talk about establishment politics you
know Trump's Firebrand much credit to
him was anti-establishment drained the
swamp and that was a great great
marketing tool for him in 2016. but I
think the the the overall temperature of
the country is just like Trump
thanks bro but keep it moving and
everybody in the establishment is going
to do everything they can from McConnell
to McCarthy to Romney all the way down
to ensure that even if it's close
meatball round is going to be the uh the
the nomination any different thoughts
you guys have before we go into a
different story
um just on that they changed the rules
on Bernie for debates and stuff because
they didn't really the mainstream
Democrats and the DNC panicked they
didn't think that the Bernie Elizabeth
Warren message was Central enough and
they really wanted to come back to
Central and they had Bill Clinton in
their ear yes you know pimping for
Hillary if you can use pimping and Bill
Clinton in the same sentence the um and
because that's where he wanted it right
so they said hey you got to be back on
the Senate on the center and Bernie and
Elizabeth are too far out there and they
changed the rules for some of the debate
or you don't qualify for this debate
Bernie what are you talking about and so
there's that that was rules but you just
kind of proved my point though is the
previous point about rules so I don't
think you need any rules right
Adam on one okay one thing here I don't
think the RNC needs to bend any rules to
put DeSantis at the center of the stage
it's happening because he's getting
there under his own power and he's just
there Bernie was the outlier Canada and
was getting there was too much over
there and they wanted the votes to come
back to the center and to Galvanize
their support because they were really
worried about the election and so they
changed the rules I don't think the RNC
has changed in any rules uh in this
Hannah's favor I think they're letting
that roll and they're and people are
supporting them and he's raising the
money so from an optic standpoint one
could argue that Trump is more like the
Bernie back then and DeSantis is more
like the Hillary Clinton today correct
today there's a lot of establishment
like Fox choosing to ignore him but I'm
with Pat we haven't even seen this war
start to start yet we have not seen it
yet and it's coming anyway this is
really fast and this is this is the
Republican fight I read an article on
New York Times I sent to Rob that Biden
for him for his run his 2024 Playbook is
going to be the 2020 Playbook just you
know kind of hide let these guys go nuts
and this was a statement on it uh Pat it
said whether uh ultimately he faces
Donald Trump this is Biden or another
Republican trying to be like Mr Trump
Biden plans a campaign message that
still boils down to three words
competent beats crazy that's gonna be
yeah his side no matter who goes because
if the Santa's plays that you know trump
card which he kind of is you know saying
he blew up with that Trump attitude
that's how that's how that that slogan
won't work against DeSantis because he's
not crazy he's competent and that's the
ironic part is that at my last point I
think Biden as inefficient and as weak
as he's proven to be would still beat
Trump in 2024. you really think that
well he already did it he already did it
and there's a chance he could do it
that's how tarnish trumps look at the
polls guys
last Point DeSantis would wipe out
vitamins I love how everybody's laughing
I love how everybody's laughing I said
this exact same thing about 2020. you're
crazy you're crazy I'll tell you what's
different there's a difference there's
there's here's what's different okay so
you know the whole uh uh fraud election
whatever whatever they talk I'm not even
talking about ballots I'm not talking
about the 2000 mules I'm not talking any
of that stuff set that stuff aside you
believe it happened you didn't believe
it happened it is what it is that's been
happening for a long time you guys got
to get it better at catching these
things happening I'm not even going
there uh Hunter Biden's story
if that story State he ain't getting
reelected when James Comey came out with
the story about Hillary Clinton a week
before election Hillary lost believe it
or not as much as James Comey as Hillary
Clinton's best friend he caused her to
lose he could have waited a one and a
half week more Trump ain't winning
Tom and I are on the phone at 3 30 in
the morning were shell shocked when they
announced Trump one and Hillary Clinton
had to call and concede we're like
are you awake is this a like what the
hell is going on that was James Comey
okay because it was a week out that New
York uh post story was a week out fast
forward to today the amount of content
this is the part about being the
president you give your enemies a lot of
content okay your enemies you don't have
any content on your enemies because he's
been on the bench Trump's not been
active he's been on the bench for the
last four years right Biden's been on
the bench Trump has 15 different things
he can bring up about Biden
my concern he goes against Biden he
beats Biden I don't think I think that
the Santa's part is a concern if the
left picks somebody else
if it's a Michelle if it's someone else
it's a different story but I think
Biden's resume is not sitting pretty
he's gonna okay you ready all right 83
billion dollars Afghanistan okay uh what
do you call it Hunter byton laptop you
got uh Ukraine world war three first
time since 1970 that Russia has put you
know nuclear weapons on their ships do
you want me to keep going what happens
with China and Iran and Russia unifying
becoming a new world order in the other
side that the New World Order you made
the three enemies of America become
United what the hell are you doing what
kind of diplomacy is that he he is
destroyed in that area so Trump's going
to play to that card no problem I think
Democrats truly have to figure out a way
to get Biden to step aside and bring
somebody else in they need somebody else
I don't think Biden's going to win
against him anyways okay did you guys
see the very uh Pleasant looking
friendly girl going around yesterday on
the Jan the Georgia election probe did
you guys see our friend go to the MSNBC
is this the one no I sent you the last
one that I just uh uh no no not that one
did you guys see this or no do the one
I'm about to send you here I don't think
as a 44 year old man I mean I've watched
exorcists it freaked me out uh I've
watched Stigmata very respectable scary
movie I've watched uh what else you want
to put out there Nightmare on Elm Street
when I was eight years old in Iran but I
tell you the last time I was this scared
was when I watched The Exorcist until I
watched this girl on the interview you
know she reminded me of pause it real
quick she remind how many guys I've seen
a movie Fallen you've seen a movie
following with Denzel Washington of
course
yes it is do you remember when the guy
is making these faces you know what I'm
gonna of course you creepy guy behind
the glass who knows what I'm talking
about he touches them boom Spirit goes
watch this girl
she's not acting okay it's the real life
life Fallen character okay play this
clip you should just watch this I mean
you're not after you watch this you're
going to be into men just watch this for
a second God watch it watch it
watch your facial reaction here what can
you tell us about how many people oh my
God as a group to face indictments
look at that I well thank you for having
me first of all and I'm I'm hesitant to
speak to something that the judge made a
decision not to share
he uh I don't know if everyone's aware
of this but there was a hearing
um
about what parts of the report should
and should not be published in its
various forms and the list well the
sections that were removed were
consciously chosen to be removed and I
don't want to say I have better judgment
than the judge
that's totally understandable is it
would you say when it comes to there are
there are indictments recommended look
at that is it more than 12 people is it
more than 20 people
I think if you look at the page numbers
of the report there's about
six pages in the middle that got cut out
allow for spacing
it's not a short list
not a short list
oh my god when it comes to 75 Witnesses
like is it it's not I assume of course
it's about 75. pause it you know who she
reminds me of how many guys have seen
the movie Wedding Crashers anyone seen
wedding yeah
I'll find you you're like holy [__]
anyways I'm into it Vinnie I'm into it I
know you are Vinnie uh uh you see this
with the story on what's going on and
and Tom I know you watched the news how
they were reacting to it and what they
said about this what are your reaction
when you see this well in mind you in
time we talked about this in the back
she's the four so this is for the grand
jury for for Trump so just let them know
who she is basically in church she's a
four person four woman for for picking
all the jurors and and keeping
everything in line she's the most biased
there was a interview there's another
interview before this one where she's
rubbing her hands and she goes um if
Trump is going to come in there she's
like I want to be the one to be like you
know to give that that brief that they
do this is another prime example of the
bias that they're used using on the left
which is going to hurt them because what
they say Tom what did um I think it was
CNN or something she's ruined she's
ruined the whole that's a whole whole
the courtroom thing is all finished you
have fair-minded legal analysts that are
on the left that are just they
understand how it works when you go into
a courtroom and they're looking at this
and they're saying
she is the defense attorney's dream
because they're going to walk in here
and say my client has been indicted on a
grand jury that had so much bias and a
violation of the confidential
requirement on the jurists
which one of these interview tour and
you saw Democrats that were saying she's
on this interview tour what the hell
what the hell she doesn't have a
publicist she doesn't have this they're
calling her up and they're giving she's
paid to be on these programs they pay
you to be on these things whether it's
five grand or 10 grand you're normally
paid and you've got these Democrats are
out there going she's on a freaking
media tour you can't do that as a four
person we work so hard to get this guy
on the mat and to pin him down and get
this grand jury to indict him and she
just blew the whole thing up right there
it is they're worried about it so you
actually the funny part of it the same
facial expressions are being made by
democrats yesterday going I can't
believe this you know they were just a
question for you you know you know what
I think about like you know how
sometimes we have somebody that like
tomorrow I'm interviewing uh uh uh we're
trying to get this on the calendar to
interview Tate's attorney right that
they reached out and so I'll be
interviewing Tate's attorney and I will
put that out live uh annual will see
it's going to be all over the place when
they talk about that so we we have
conversations before that interview
takes place so imagine you're the
producer working on that show and you're
checking her audio so Mary Emily is
everything good
you're like hey bro can you come and see
this girl today
how's the weather where you're at she's
making these faces yeah dude I think
this is like
you know what I can't hear you click
right you can't have this person we got
to change bring somebody else in to
replace us why would you even put this
on air this is not helping you out these
are just like these are turnovers and
interception that you just gave to this
other guy named Donald Trump and uh he's
gonna run with this when you see
something like this so look at Emily
course the reporter does that look like
a woman that's reacting here it looks
like she had bad sushi at lunch and
she's about to just open her mouth and
here it comes she is in pain you see her
sitting there asking questions as this
was unfolding she's not Emily cores is
not a not a dumb person she's an
intelligent good interviewer
I'm not a mind reader but I'll tell you
she's looking at this going oh my gosh
Kate Baldwin Kate Baldwin it looked a
lot yeah
she's she's getting sick so so okay so
we just kind of wanted to show you guys
this to inspire you anyway shout out to
Emily give me a call if you're how many
times
oh my can somebody get a hold of her and
introduce Emily to Adam because there's
a reason why he's uh 39 and single
because he chases Emily's that's the
problem so anyways not so much all right
so here's the next thing I want to talk
about parents you already we talk about
you to you don't don't show up the stuff
on the on the thing I just want to first
uh ask the question you can put it there
so I can see it but not for them to see
it so right now following leading cause
of death
for people ages 1 to 44. okay they call
this the youth younger ages 1 to 44.
cancer heart disease homicide Motor
Vehicles suicide and drug overdose
historically in 1980 up until 2000 drug
overdose was last by mile this data just
came out by the CDC I want you to take a
look at this can you put this up
take a look at this you guys on what's
happened okay look at HIV in 86 it goes
up boom flat line it's pretty much gone
they're not even tracking the stats
anymore like they did before
heart disease going slightly lower you
got cancer is around homicide is there
accidents is gone lower look at these
poisoning drug overdoses and the number
000 and climbing 50
000 and climbing okay so when you see
this what do you think about Tom my mind
goes to a couple different places where
do you go when you see a stat like this
as a parent
this scares the hell out of me and and
there is a story behind the story here
that fentanyl is being intentionally
shipped to this country in illegal drugs
and the nation's children are getting a
hold of it and they're just they're you
know they're dropping a tab parting and
it turns out that it's laced and that's
what's going on here and it's horrifying
and I don't think anybody wants to talk
about it when I see like this it just
underlines just why I've been so
proactive so early with my kids because
the internet and everything that's
happened
so much earlier in life getting a hold
of my girls before my parents got a hold
of me because of what's out there and
realizing it only takes one man we used
to talk in the late 80s you look at HIV
there and so I graduated
um high school early 80s and so back
then take a look at the HIV line my
parents used to say you got to be
careful it only takes one time and you
can get HIV it only takes one time time
HIV and it was considered the death
sentence back then before AZT protease
Inhibitors and all the things that build
the Cocktails so that people can live
like Magic Johnson many many many
decades this it only takes one and
you're out and it just scares the hell
out of me and Pat I actually lost uh my
mom knows I lost two friends uh mom
about a year ago my friend fukuan and my
boy Rico they were just hanging out they
trusted this girl they were just at a
house you know L.A they're chilling uh
one of them had his girlfriend with them
apparently they all did just one little
you know little bit of cocaine all three
dead the other girl OD but she survived
and this is and I think we talked about
last podcast Pat this is and you said
because um yeah some of it's coming over
the Border but one of the main ones that
flatnell is coming in here is from China
okay so China's winning bro I mean we
owe them all this money they're making
not the money that they owe us but uh we
owe them they're making money on the
Fentanyl and they're killing Americans
so it's it's a win-win for them and
nobody that's that's not a big deal to
people
your great uncle you spend a lot of time
with your not a great uncle meaning he's
got you know
very good yeah not an old Uncle great
Uncle Robert and you have a nephew what
do you think about this story well I
think there's uh um I too have lost some
friends in Miami that have um
overdosed Rob can you pull up that that
graph I think there's a few things going
on right here you could see that it
really boom takes off around 2010 right
which is right around the time when
social media started blowing up so you
know the the the the the you know what's
that what's the term when you um can you
put out the chart for the audience Jorge
or Eric go ahead what's the term when
you uh the fear of missing out fomo I
think social media has a major pro has
been a major factor at this if you can
just you know what do they say like the
most dangerous people in the world right
now are lonely sexless men sitting in
their basement so to speak and if you
are just home on your phone and everyone
out there is living their best life and
you just buy yourself and you're a 16
year old kid 22 year old kid 24 year old
guy whatever it is and everyone's having
a great time and you're home alone and
you're doing some sort of drug by
yourself I think social media has led to
that and then I think what is even worse
as you can see was trending upward and
then since covet it is just skyrocketed
and that's sad because what you don't
hear people saying is get the hell out
of your house exercise go hang out with
friends be a human get out there like
thank you and you don't hear people
talking about that you hear people
saying you know take the pill take the
jab get you know get surgery quick fixes
no like you know one of the things that
I give you major credit for Lincoln on
leadership is no we're not all [__]
working remote we're going to be around
each other and we're going to be amongst
each other we're going to create a
culture we're going to have teamwork
we're going to hold each other
accountable and I think from for for
young people out there there's just this
you know lack of friendship and a lack
of togetherness and even if it's in
school that's fine but then you go home
and you go on your iPad and you're alone
and you don't know what kind of thoughts
are going through people's heads when
they're home alone in front of a screen
and I think it's incumbent on parents I
think it's incumbent on teachers I think
it's a comment on friends I think it's a
comment on family to just check in on
people that you think may have a problem
and even kids that you don't have a
problem and I think this is a this is an
American issue that we need to cut to
tackle it's such I think that's a great
point one one quick point out to cut you
off I I like that they're using
poisoning because I don't think your
friends Adam like mine they didn't OD
they didn't sit there and shoot up my
friends were poisoned because this girl
got whatever they got the drugs from
whoever that [__] was poison because
they weren't sitting there they did one
bump of cocaine and they were all dead
because fentanyl the the amount that
fits on the top of this can kill your
ass so I I don't think it's you bring up
really good friend I would like to know
because I've lost friends for from
overdoses right they we know that they
had problems they were partying and and
we all I mean show of hands if you know
somebody that has passed away from some
sort of Overdose this is an American
problem that we're all dealing with so
the poisoning I think is one small
percentage of it I'd like to know the
stats on that I don't know too many
people are like I don't do any drugs
boom I died I think a lot of it is like
this Collective drip drip drip drip drip
drip drip boom now you've just overdosed
so it's it's a sad situation that we
need to talk about what you bring up
about social media I think is really
important the the irony of the election
of Donald Trump happened at a time
remember we were talking about Facebook
we were worried about the addiction of
kids and then as soon as the election
happened we were worried about Facebook
about Russian interference and
everything like that there was a
dialogue that was going on in the United
States about how kids were being hyper
addicted to social media and how there
were whistleblowers inside Facebook that
said you know we've kind of programmed
it this way to keep you in to keep you
chasing likes that your your self-worth
Earth was I was connected to your social
measurement measured by how many people
like you you had to be crazier more
outrageous the makeup whatever you were
doing had to be more more to get the
likes and that kind of stopped and went
to the side and then we had hearings on
okay you social media guys how do we get
the orange man elected what happened
here and it moved to that and you know
um I went to a movie recently and both
my wife and I anybody see the Dove soap
commercial in the movie where the the
ladies talking to her daughter and
they're talking about the risk of social
media and everything like that I think I
think this dialogue has to consider be
considered because I could call that the
Zuckerberg line because why are you
taking the drugs why are you dropping
these tabs what is so necessary about
partying and doing it you're getting
poisoned by the drug you're taking but
why is it that you're turning to do that
and I happen to think social media is a
big part of it so so a social dilemma is
a documentary that how many guys watched
the documentary social dilemma a lot of
people thinking talk and all this stuff
but you know I will tell you this
yesterday we're doing a elite Mastermind
and one of my favorite guys you guys
know who he is uh uh he's asking
questions saying you know I'm afraid uh
this happening to me I'm afraid of
making this decision what if this goes
wrong what if at 70 I work hard I build
my company but nothing happens and this
this this that I said why is it for the
last three years every time I talk to
you you always come from a place of fear
and he says I don't know I said uh do
you believe in God he says Ah as he says
I'm in uh you know I'm in this country
where it's the number one country in the
world for atheists I said okay I said
you go to church he says I don't go to
church I said what do you think about
faith he says no not really I'm not big
on it so I said I'm going to recommend a
book to you I don't know if you're going
to read it or not but I highly recommend
you read it I said let me tell you what
I noticed that I want you to be thinking
about he says because when I watch you I
watch how hard you work and how many
things you're doing but how come you
don't seem stressed out and you're just
kind of enjoying the process you got a
wife you got four kids you're running
these businesses all this other stuff
how come you don't seem like you're
overwhelmed like you're just kind of
going with the flow I said dude it's
only because I truly believe someone's
got my back and by the way I'm not here
you you will rarely ever hear me talk
about my faith but I think there's a few
different things peer pressure is a good
thing if it's the right peers peer
pressure is a bad thing if it's the
right wrong peers we need better peer
pressure the right peer pressure forces
you to make better decisions because you
don't want to let down to people in your
community there was a form of a peer
pressure this morning when we were
having a meeting back there it's between
us but you know exactly what I'm talking
about peer pressure is a good thing I
think people need to start spending more
time in churches I think whatever you
practice go do it this goes back to the
clip we talked about with Robert Downey
Jr and Mel Gibson the other day about
the fact that how many guys I've seen
the whole Robert Downey Jr Mel Gibson
where he says
the reason why I brought Mel Gibson here
is because years ago when I had nothing
going on and I was an alcoholic Mel came
up to me and well I couldn't pay the
bills I couldn't pay rent I couldn't we
can't play this because the music I
couldn't do this I couldn't do that he
gave me a job and that job put a roof
over my head and I asked him I said how
can I ever pay you back because you know
Robert Downey Jr is not blowing up he
says he told me go find your faith he
says Mel never told me which Faith he
just said go find your faith whatever
that Faith may be and it starts with
responsibility Robert Downey Jr is
happily married quiet low-key you don't
see him at the clubs any of that stuff
and to me one of my favorite I don't
know if you guys like this guy I love
Robert Downey Jr's acting how he is a
story Underdog Redemption any of that
stuff and he says later on when you go
through this pass this down to somebody
else so a lot of these drugs that you're
seeing we can blame social media we can
blame all of that stuff people are
uncomfortable talking about taking
people to go to church going to a
faith-based and environment and having
the right people around you the better
the peers you have around you better
Community you're a part of you're going
to perform better when I when I was
around other guys and at one point I was
a bodyguard most people don't know the
story if you really know the story you
really follow our contents I've only
told the story one other time as a
bodyguard for a Colombian guy
and he didn't sell baseball cards you
know what I'm saying so so one day we go
out and I'm hanging out with these guys
first of all we're having a Time Of Our
Lives just so you know because
Colombia's they know how to party but
this Colombian guy was a very well-known
Colombian guy in L.A
you don't need to know who he is but he
was a very built no Colombian guy and I
was a very well-known you know
tough guy tough guy not a tough guy but
I would say I was a very well-known guy
that I could handle myself in pressure
type situations however way you wanted
to find that right so we meet we go out
all of a sudden I'm on a uh yacht and
Marina Del Rey and there's a mountain of
this White Mountain you know if you want
to call whatever you want to call this
white mountain and he says we have to
this guy owes us a hundred thousand
dollars
I'm like so that's why I'm here yeah
great okay fantastic
so obviously we collect a hundred
thousand dollars but here's a point
while this whole thing is over with I go
back in the car and I know what I did
that night like with the people were
hanging out with I'm like dude this is
the wrong crowd to be around do you know
if I stay in that Community for two more
weeks three more weeks the guy goes to
jail by the way if I'm there for three
more months nobody came in I don't have
my four kids I will never meet Patrick I
will never meet Dylan I will never meet
Senna I will never meet Brooklyn I will
never meet these wonderful people in my
life I will never meet Mario I would
never meet Tom I would
I would never you're one stupid decision
away if you have the wrong pressure
pierced around you you get in the right
environment where they're pressuring you
to improve your marriage pressuring you
to be a better father pressuring you to
be a better friend pressuring you to be
a better person financially then one day
you wake up and you're like okay great
this is fantastic we've done okay we're
going to make mistakes you're gonna
screw up this doesn't mean just because
you have faith you're going to walk on
water but I think we need more of that
today that's all I'm talking about I
just wanted to say something
I just want to add one thing to to what
Pat says um you know he talked about
this concept of peer pressure and
whether you have good peers in your life
or bad peer pressure can be a good thing
if it leads you the right thing I think
you know you said the other day with you
know this whole concept like your
network is your net worth and then you
know if you add up the five people that
are closest around you you're the sum of
those five people and then Pat goes yeah
yeah but is it really five
or is it really one person that is sort
of the biggest influence over you and I
think we all know that it's not just
five people it's one person in your ear
whose counsel you listen to the most
whether it's a business partner whether
it's a wife whether it's a parent or
it's a friend whatever it may be and I
think you know you're absolutely right
with that and last point I think we're
so hungry in this country
for leadership and I think that's kind
of what you're talking about is that
whether it's a voice in your ear or
whether it's the president of the United
States or whether it's a friend we all
want some leaders to step up and put us
in the right direction and and this is
what I think is so amazing about you and
I know you're not big on like
you know grandstanding but we wouldn't
be where we are without your leadership
so it's not so much the five people that
we're closer to like we all look at you
as the leader and to have someone the
captain of the ship so to speak is so
big to have in your life and if it's you
that it's the person that people look at
in your life just understand people are
looking at you as the leader but if it's
somebody that is the leader in your life
just keep them close even if you uh
screw up from time to time right one
more great thing about Adam is uh never
screws up
it never screws up let's go to this next
door because we're on this here by the
way this next story to me also has to do
with the drug stuff because I think
working from home is not a good business
model because you're asking people to be
alone by themselves we need to be around
people here's a story I know some of you
guys don't agree with that I'm just
telling you how I feel about it Amazon
employees Express dismay anger about
sudden return to office policy and Tom's
got some stuff on this especially what
uh uh Bernie Sanders said recently but
let me read this article the next time
I'm coming straight to you Amazon CEO
Andy jassy will replace Jeff Bezos
announcements of a mandatory return to
office policy for at least three days a
week beginning May 1st has sparked
opposition amongst Amazon employees God
forbid you come to the office three days
a week group of tech workers have
created a slack Channel and a petition
against a mandate and about 5 000
employees have signed a petition so far
a group of employees also spammed an
internal website with messages conveying
their opposition to the new policy many
Express frustration that did have to
find arrangements for child care
Caregivers for aging parents or
potentially moved to be within commuting
distance oh my God
to the office Additionally the petition
presents a number of data points and
studies highlighting the benefits of
remote work such as improved
productivity and the ability to attract
and retain top talent Tom what are your
thoughts on this wonderful article well
this article comes on the heels of
Disney everybody see Disney also got a
petition about four days ago 2300 people
a couple people nodding here so 2300
people positioned Disney because Robert
Iger said two things hey we're a
creative organization it's good when
created people are together number one
and number two the rest of you that are
not in creative jobs here at Disney it's
good to be collaborating with each other
that's where we get mentorship that's
how you get noticed to be promoted and
so I'd like you to be in the office four
days a week four days a week that's all
that Robert Iger asked to Disney 2300
people flipped out the same thing oh
it's going to create hardships hardships
hardships then Disney comes out 72 hours
later during earnings report and it says
yeah and we gotta let you know we the
expenses are still Ohio so we probably
have to lay off about 5 000 people if I
was one of the 2300 people that just
signed a petition and then you hear him
go yo oh crap I'm in you know now what
the same thing is happening here and I
think the employees aren't understanding
they're being given opportunities to be
recognized get a raise who doesn't want
to raise unless you think you're
entitled to it and by showing up you get
it how many business owners or business
managers are here look at this look at
this how do you recognize people how do
you help people lift up how do you
notice those little things those little
intangibles somebody who's an
encouraging force in the office and so
now you have 5 000 people are signing
this petition and Amazon oh wait they
did a big layoff too in the middle of
Amazon trying to find some costs and
efficiencies
it's just amazing and also I like the
note here move within commuting distance
of the office something funny you go
look it up it happened with Yelp today
Yelp discovered that people that were
working from home actually had moved
like to Texas or Florida or some way and
we're no longer near the office and
hadn't told Yelp so when they say okay
you have to be in the office for three
days they're like oh crap
so this thing about moved within
commuting distance to the office you had
a lot of people thinking hey guess what
I can go skiing I can live in Mammoth
California and I'll don't have to come
to the office so when this comes back
there's a flip side to this employee
flip out where some of them and maybe
it's for good reasons have moved out of
areas there it is yelp's remote work
reveals how pandemic reshaped local
economies and the way we work yeah local
economies that no longer had certain
Yelp workers but they had a Yelp office
and now you have to go back to the
office and they're like whoops I don't
live here anymore it's like what are you
talking about Adam what do you think
about this
so I think this is part of a larger
conversation of this concept of a
work-life balance you know so and
there's no secret that gen Z and even
Millennials are advocating
wholeheartedly like dude let me just
live my best life a little bit more
right and I think there is some
uh justification to some of these
four-day work weeks some countries have
implemented that they've started to see
some productivity go up during four days
I mean how much time is spent in the
office just bsing you know networking
talking I mean that's part of office
culture I get it
um but what I thought as ironic here
he's requesting employees come back
three days a week as the CEO it's like
you're now mandatory need to be in the
office four days a week or five days a
week whatever it is uh but I think as a
raise your hand again if you're a
business owner
so and raise your hand if you're just by
the way if the audience can't see it can
you can you get the turn the camera on
to folks who look what percentage our
business owners raise your hands again
if you're a business owner look at this
wow wow did you say that's 90 80 yeah so
I think God bless the job creators baby
yeah respect I I think um you know at
the end of the day if I don't know who
these people are at Amazon but let's
just say that they're 40 50 000 a year
employees you know they don't own the
company they don't they they don't
haven't taken the risk as an
entrepreneur granted we can go down that
path but you know that you know regular
employee they also want to have a life
they want to have some vested interest
in their life they don't want to just
let work to live right they want to they
don't or they want to live to work and a
lot of people say well like a job j-o-b
stands for just over broke so if you are
not incentivizing your employees to say
no this is part of uh an overall life
plan that we can help you with so you
can save money and and and really live
what do you think about what Adam is
saying what are think about what Adam is
saying I'm asking you what do you think
tell me tell me what are your thoughts
with what Adam said I just I actually
want to cure but by the way what do you
do real quick what business are you in
okay
okay so what do you think so general
contractor own and uh operate properties
right yeah okay so what do you think
about what Adam said about the fact that
you know they need to have some
work-life balance what do you think
about that
businesses don't run that way and the
thing is yep
Staffing payroll costs your utilities
and overall
expenses
if you were to break it down you would
go broke instantaneously to try to help
create in that perspective now there is
incentive to help grow and the thing is
that it is my job to see whether all you
do is housekeeping or you do just Lobby
the thing is that when you see potential
you help that growth move forward
because I've I've created
with me and my family we've created
about five to seven people one works for
corporate Choice Hotels uh one became a
house Builder a premium house Builder
another one joined a major company and
she's doing fantastic with their life
but it requires time from the ownership
at the same time
you can't you can't put everybody in the
same box
and so if you were to put everybody into
the same box you would never get this
thing moving forward
and that's where like your cost won't
back you it won't it won't pencil out
you will go under if you're trying to
make a specific move just to help
everybody because it doesn't work that
way because my family didn't have
anything either when they first began by
the way it sounds like a very recent
Make some noise for a great response
here what's what's your name what's your
say it again
you know what I think about Jerry
Maguire how many guys think about Jerry
Maguire the prospect but uh going back
to what you're saying so here's kind of
how this thing works out when you're
saying you know the employees also need
a work-life balance all this other stuff
fine no problem I totally understand it
um
you know when it comes down to running a
business the goal is to stay in business
he just talked about that a lot of times
people are making the decision the way
you're thinking where let's try to
please everybody but then if the company
goes out of business you just cost a few
hundred thousand people jobs or
thousands of people a job Bed Bath and
Beyond going out of business to please a
few employees they just shut down 436
something stores who did that hurt so
let's sit there and try to please
everybody that you know want a little
bit work life balance guess what you
want work life balance go be a laptop
entrepreneur figure out a make fifty
thousand dollars you know live in
Thailand if that's what you want to do
but if you want to run a company
shout out goes to the people that are
creating jobs the job creators in
America lower taxes let me explain to
you this there is nobody that lowers
taxes in America more than job creators
if a person is employed
that company is minimizing your taxes
because you don't have to pay
unemployment taxes you don't have to pay
entitlement programs that company's
taking the responsibility of doing that
the more of these companies that are
doing that you and I are able to pay
lower and lower taxes shout out to them
now let me give you the other part as
well
50 Cent uh we talked about this on
Tuesday where he said too many people
the the concept of being depressed it's
a luxury to be depressed okay it's a
luxury to be depressed for me some of
the most miserable bitter people I've
met in my life have way too much time on
their hands
some of the most miserable bitter people
who do stupid [__] have way too much
time on their hands you know what I did
when I had a lot of time on my hands my
hair was orange
[Laughter]
because I was born
so I'm kind of like you know what I'm
going to try this peroxide [__] and you
know
who's done the peroxide thing before who
knows what I'm looking at you guys I'm
not alone yeah I'm like let me see let's
go to the beach hey my hair is orange
damn that's
damn that yeah I don't have a job
okay so no we have a little too much
time on our hands where people need to
kind of get back to work and have a
bigger purpose life without a purpose is
when you start doing stupid things drugs
alcohol dump stuff
coloring your hair all these other crazy
activities that comes in the more active
you are the more you're in the hunt for
something big for you for your family
for your kids whatever it may be you're
gonna be a better productive citizen for
all of us and the communities become
safer if we do that I I don't wanna I I
want you give them around give pop come
on guys I mean
not but with that being said not to put
a damper on everything but you know
Dodge are in the field reporting Ohio
he's dead and it just so he's dead now
so the water in Ohio let me just give a
quick by the way shout out to you uh
great dresser I mean respect to you push
but you hit the nail on the head is that
that
how many more entrepreneurs business
owners
are there versus actual employees 90 10
let's say so so I think what's important
for you to do is is those people with
jobs they need to understand that they
are a part of a company that is doing
something and is an incumbent I agree
with yeah it is I agree with you to
validate their purpose yes because look
you're not talking to somebody that's
some fifty thousand dollar employee I I
have a company like it is so true like
I'm not that dude that that this is that
that you think I am like I'm just so but
what I do is I talk to a lot of
employees and what I've what I've
noticed is there's like yeah it's just a
job and I'm like what do you mean we're
building something here bro like this is
what we're doing they're like no just
just a job for me and there's a
disconnect between the entrepreneur
who's building something and has a
vision and wants to do something and is
putting in and sleeping you know four
hours a night and it's doing something
versus the guy that just hey this is
just a job and if you can make that
person feel important and make that
person feel like he has a purpose and
he's part of something that's actually
building something that's where you get
someone to buy in and whether it's three
days a week or five days a week he's
part of the vision you make a very good
point very very important Point let me
tell you what happened remember how the
whole thing where it's some people
shouldn't become fathers because you're
not like you need to just take your time
before you become a father because
you're not willing to do the job it
takes two minutes to become a dad it
takes years to become a father of that
whole Saint amen certain people are not
to meant to become employers
so where's Leo at if Leo's in here or
not Leo do you remember when we were in
that one house in Bay Colony and one of
the guy was talking about well two years
ago I made 10 million dollars in profit
life was good I'm doing this I'm doing
that but I'm having a hard time keeping
employees you know why do you think I'm
having a hard time keeping employees I
said interesting I said tell me your
schedule how often are you at the office
are you working 60 I said when you made
10 million how much were you working 60
hours a week I said how did you work
last year now last year I'm probably
more like 10 to 20 hours a week
I said so the employee is sitting there
asking themselves why the hell am I
working for you
exactly
if the leader at the top is not driving
the company what the hell am I doing
because if you're growing hey I'll ride
that uh train but if you're not what am
I doing with you I'm gonna go and work
for somebody else exactly so I fully
agree with the point you're making as
well some some employers need to go
become more in a supporting role and be
an employee if you don't want that kind
of pressure if you're the employer if
you're the CEO founder you got to work
drive the company and sell division of
where they're going so other people are
willing to go out there and join you if
not go join somebody else's team very
good point you made there as well so we
got a couple things here before we wrap
up I got one last story we can do okay
we can do one of the five and you pick
and choose which one based on the noise
you milk will pick one of them one of
them is a masks Story by New York Times
let me give you the list and you pick
and choose the other one is Putin's
speech about the family nucleus anybody
stop putting speech about family nucleus
if you haven't seen it I retweeted it
yesterday and you should go read the
commentary it's awesome they were all
very friendly towards me it was is
incredible babe you shouldn't read what
people have to say everybody else you
can go enjoy it we can talk world war
three or we can talk
um office landlord defaults or
escalating as lenders brace more for
distress pick one of those four stories
or chat gbt that ask the question which
one of these people's social score is
the highest in America into the world
which of those five you want to talk
about you pick and choose the audience
really okay let's get the Putin speech
you've got a bunch of Russians in the
house hello here we go
right okay so Putin gives a speech and
you know he's talking to the the I mean
you'll see when he's going through it
but he gives a speech about the family
nucleus and how America is making a big
mistake right now and what's causing a
fall and then we'll get some reaction
here from everybody go out and play the
clip if you can okay
you guys can read it
yeah okay go back turn off the audio
I'll read it on what he's saying so go
back and turn off the audio and put it
on one point uh five speed I'll read it
at a fast pace if you want to press play
one request what's that please read it
in a Russian accent hello yeah we're not
we're not doing that yeah I already have
an accent let alone the Russian I mean I
can do it press play and here they lie
constantly perverts historical facts do
not stop attacks on our culture
the Russian Orthodox church and other
traditional religious organizations of
our country
see what they do with their own peoples
the destruction of the family cultural
national identity
super slow talking perversion mockery of
children and pedophilia are declared the
norm he's talking about America
pedophilia is the norm the norm of their
life and Priests are forced to bless
same-sex marriages
interesting
god with them let them do what they want
to do what do I want to say here adults
have the right to live as they want we
have always thought like this in Russia
we always will
no one will invade private life we are
not going to do this
so far sounds reasonable but I want to
tell them look at the holy scriptures
the main books of all other religious
world religions everything is said there
including that the family is the union
of a man and a woman
so they're clapping right now yes great
hat yeah
but these sacred texts are now in doubt
as it became known the end angle uh
Anglican Church for example plans to
consider the idea of gender neutral God
oh my God what can we say forgive us
Lord they do not know what they do wow
everybody clap clap
millions of people in the west
understand that they are leading to a
real spiritual disaster
the elites directly I must say go crazy
and it seems that they can no longer be
treated
but these are their problems as I said
and we must protect our children
and we will do this protect our children
from degradation and degeneration and
the speech is over with so what are your
thoughts about that speech that he gives
okay what do you think about it okay so
now
Tom uh Adam I'll go to you first you
hear a speech like that he's given Putin
the commentary is 50 50. you just want
to prepare you the commentary is 50 50.
what do you think when you hear him give
a speech like that about America uh well
I think if any leader made a speech like
that we would all kind of be like yeah
like let's return to normal and let's
just you know respect religion and you
know probably we're not going to invade
your private lives I think when a thug
like Putin gives that speech you
automatically are like okay if you
disagree you'll die so uh
again a lot of what he said makes sense
and by the way show of hands if you're
like a fan of Putin in this room
okay so it's not like we have a okay we
have a couple and just why are you a fan
of Putin a fan
you like Putin I get what a fan is but
why are you a fan
you like Russian history okay you're
like the Russian history and are you a
capitalist yourself are you pro-america
or no
you name your boy after Stalin your son
can we get the KGB in here
where's the key by the way you're being
serious are you you're a trolling right
now straight up you know what I love
about this here's what I love how long
you've been following our content
20 2015 2016 you've been following the
content okay so why do you like uh Putin
uh just what I read about history like
Russia yeah so I read about all his like
Russia like Glenn in Stalin
what are your thoughts on Lennon and
Stalin fan
well I read their books I read all of
them so you're a fan I'm not a fan I
read all history I like history I like
America history I like I've read
mindconf about Adolf Hitler but I'm not
a fan yeah I read mankind too nice are
you a fan no I'm not a fan okay got it
all right but you're a fan of Putin I
like Russia and German history every
history really history history okay how
do you view Putin as an individual like
how he's doing as a leader of his
country and then who he is to US America
is he a pro West is he a fan of what
we're doing or is he a enemy the state
number one well if we have to go to war
with them I would
like if it was between us and Them
I'll put it that way meaning what you
you would yeah I would say I have to
fight him okay interesting yeah where
were you going with that Adam what was
your point well I just wanted to get to
read the room because there seems to be
this like fascination with Putin and you
can have respect for somebody and even
what they stand for but at the same time
understand that he's a bad dude he he
wants to bring down America he wants to
bring down the West he's not uh on Team
America whatsoever uh and I think part
of our country right now is that whether
you're on team red or team blue just
remember you should be on team red white
and blue and I think that's just
something that you know who who'd we
have on the other day was it Jimmy Dore
that was talking about what Tucker
Carlson is saying about
uh Putin I don't remember if it was him
or not but uh Tom what do you think
about this so I believe that that is a
political speech and he was preaching to
the choir that was there that was his
military industrial front line there in
the first two rows mednadev you could
see him sent right there
and so I number one I think he's
trolling us a little bit but number one
I think he's trolling us with the
reflective truth of one side because I
think he's trying to divide
but I have to tell you if I close my
eyes I didn't know who was speaking and
I heard that
um there's a lot of Truth in it and
there's a lot of stuff in that that I'm
like yeah that's correct yeah that's
true this is what we are doing to a
generation of children so I see that
part of it but then I say okay why is
this guy saying it and saying it now and
saying it this way I think he's trolling
and CR trying to create political
division Among Us I I agree and it's
like right that's like you said he's
rallying the troops back because with
everything that's happening right now
he's just reaffirming to all of them
where where he stands and where they are
as a as a nation
that's it that's it
okay I think he believes and I think
there's parts of it that he absolutely
believes but I think he's trolling so
let me ask you what is the likelihood in
the next 20 years that a president from
the right or the left or the middle
tells that speech in his own or her own
way
would it be more from the left or right
or the middle
oh it's coming from the right oh yeah a
speech like that will come from the
right order in the U.S you mean here in
the U.S U.S leader yep so so maybe so
what is the right uh turned on by that
speech like what did he say did he say
low taxes did he say pro-military did he
what did he talk about pro-marriage he
talked Family Values he talked uh uh God
he talked leave our kids alone and
parents resonate with that story it
would be great if an American president
gave a message like that to protect
parents to say leave our kids to hell
alone that's it and by the way I'm
willing to tell you
I'm willing to tell you if that
president that presidential candidate is
left right or Center we would all
applaud for that person it doesn't
matter but somehow some way a basic
message like that doesn't come from the
left period and what's going to happen
is you're going to piss off moms who are
sitting there saying dude listen man you
can do whatever you want to me go for it
you cross the line when you mess with my
baby you're going to see a different
side of me you ever seen like my wife if
you ever talk to her I didn't think she
was naturally like this nice all the
time she's like this all the time by the
way I thought it was like an act like
I'm like you can't be like this all the
time there's got to be an act so so you
know when you date you get into some
fights and you're like you see a
different side and I've seen some sides
I'm like okay cool there you go so you
know the the breaking point you do
something to any of our kids
Jen goes from straight up playing with
her hair like this look what she's doing
right now playing with her hair she goes
from that to straight up like gangster
coming out you know a whole different
person shows up she's ready to you know
throw down but that's what's happening
to moms moms are resonating with a
message like this if a strategist is
there seeing a video like this I tweeted
I don't know how many millions of views
of God just listed I got like 40 30 000
like seven thousand retweets
hate candidates this is an important
message for American people you may want
to consider realizing how important this
is to people go yeah the message will
not will fall upon deaf ears because it
is Putin giving the speech and
everyone's like okay buddy keep it
moving but let's just let's just go back
three to six months there was the newly
elected Italian Prime Minister what's
her name again Georgia Maloney
she gave a very similar speech and it
was it was it went worldwide and I think
that's what I think you're you're I mean
that's kind of where Jenna's going
parents are just saying yeah leave us
alone let us raise our kid and there's
nothing wrong with that when it comes
from Putin I don't know about all that
though okay over under uh Adam has a kid
within two years yes or no how many guys
say he's gonna have a kid within two
years raise your hand
how many guys say there's no way in the
world he's having a kid within two years
okay hey you see all right we're gonna
see what's going it's about a certain
girl that would probably have a say in
this that girl Emily is your girl
although we were waiting for you where
are you anyways hey appreciate you guys
for coming out uh uh live audience if
you're watching this we got I'm gonna do
a podcast tomorrow hang tight with the
interview in case it does take place
you'll uh we'll let you know if we're
going live with it uh Eric do we have
that clip to show them where the next
live ones gonna be here do we have that
thumbnail to show I think it's in April
it's going to be the first week of April
or so first or second week of April
we'll be doing the next lap if you
weren't here you missed it we can't wait
for you guys to come in the problem was
the moment we announced within a couple
hours it sold out so we got a lot of
complaints well how about this how about
that if you want to be on the list next
time we're no longer announcing it
publicly we just put it in a text and it
sells out text award podcast
two three one zero three four zero one
one three two once again text award
podcast three one zero three four zero
one one three two to find out the next
time we do a live like this with that
being said we will dismiss the audience
out there but we're gonna spend a little
bit more time with the folks here take
care everybody bye bye bye bye
awesome